[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
more
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
my
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
mom
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
wow
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
one
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome guys to the toc tekken online
challenge event for the middle east
wishing you all a good morning good
afternoon or even a good evening from
wherever in the world you're watching
from we're here today to bring you some
of that good tekken i know you guys have
been craving for so it's been long
overdue but you know i'm bubsy i am back
and i'm joined by my partner in crime um
i wouldn't say crime because we we're
law abiding citizens over here mr sparks
back how have you been mate i've been
good man yo yo
it's back the dream team is back is the
second world tour 2017 2018 what's going
on here man doug and bubsy back on the
mic how you doing bro i mean i'm excited
for today i'm good man you know i'm
keeping healthy i'm well i am excited to
be back and i'm excited to see these
games excited to see
how the scenes leveled up i love that i
love i love getting that feeling just
seen yeah
yeah you've seen how it is for uh for
europe and other regions america there's
been so much new talent coming out the
woodworks and and middle east why we're
so excited is because it's a it's a
region which hasn't really been able to
get a lot of limelight in in in the
recent years you know from for many
games but second i feel like led the
front when it came to uh putting this
region on the map when it comes to big
events and we were there for the dubai
2019 master event where we were able to
see so many top talent people uh
talented tekken players one of them you
know who's going to be here today who
managed to even beat someone like
ursuline ash and tournament you know
luffy the saudi arabia's gonna be
involved israel there's so many
countries that you don't usually get to
see that are going to be here competing
today ladies and gents tlc master event
middle east um again though a shout out
to astro gaming the sponsor for the tech
online challenge uh the official headset
and mix amp of tlc 2021 it's a big shout
out to them but yeah bob's as we were
saying you know excited to see
what the results gonna be because i
can't really call it we know some of the
players but yes there's other players
that we haven't heard of that are super
good i've been watching some of the
matches on stream and man these guys are
really really strong yeah it's that's
that's the beauty of the world tour and
the beauty of these online events is
that we get to dive and see these
players that you know you may not
predominantly see i know
like you said it's an unexplored region
really you've got the americas you've
got the europeans that are at the
forefront you see them a lot but it's
great that now we have these events that
can push these guys
there's no doubt that we're going to see
some high level tekken there's no doubt
here i have no doubt in my mind we're
going to see 100 high level tech in here
and it's going to be great to see some
of these players make a name for
themselves that's what i really like
about these kind of events
yeah exactly that's that's that's what
it's all been about like 2019 it was a
year where i feel like we were exposed
to a whole a whole new country of tekken
you know second players that come and
shook the tekken world and i know
because
during that time when i was traveling
we went to the middle east we managed to
see
one of the most diverse tournaments with
many many flags represented we got
players from egypt and all all around
jordan and this and um that were
competing in the dubai event we're like
damn now these guys are really strong um
and who knows man maybe maybe today
we'll be able to see some of those guys
break into the top eight and and and you
know get that dub and it's very
important as well because we're probably
gonna look at the leaderboard very
shortly and have a look actually here it
is yeah and right now we have ultra
instinct potato at number one uh from
georgia with 95 points we have some
saudis we've got a jordanian in there
and an israeli as sixth uh but if you
actually look at the the standings
there's you know even first place has
hardly any points because they haven't
had the amount of dojo events that other
regions have had so you know this master
event you win it you win 300 points
whoever wins today is going to get that
number one position so it's very
important it's definitely we were
speaking about this just before um like
you said the winner gets 300 and there's
220 i think it's 150 and 100 if i got
the maths right for one to four but like
we said a win here could really just it
can shape how they um it definitely
gonna shape the standards you're gonna
have
someone can really be in the lead right
really take the lead here so take the
initiative guys i want to see some clean
you know yeah and you see that there's a
few saudi arabians in there and there's
so many of them competing here today as
well yeah um and that's that's a region
which i feel like is next to really
break onto the scene we have players
like bmns and this is someone who has
been from the early days in tekken tag
two yeah i remember you know he was he
was winning tournaments and like
breaking into top eight for american
mages when he was living in the u.s for
for a while um there was even other
players from saudi would you remember
that king player what was his name
yeah so like saudi arabia like has been
doing things before even like tekken 7
came out right
but there's so many players there that
are super super strong that can do um
that can do damage here and but let's
see maybe saudi arabia won't even win
that's that's what i'm interested to see
because saudi i think are the favorites
to win here today in the middle east you
know we i i do like a little upset
myself so it'll be interesting like i
said it's unexplored i may not be i'm
not familiar with all the players but
you know this this is what i like this
is this is what tekken's about i want to
see these new players i want to see this
new level i want to see these guys make
a name for themselves today you know
yeah absolutely man i think we will be
showing you the bracket very shortly um
but we do have a few of the top eight
qualified matches to show you um you
know that's that's that's the exciting
stuff right there man the shark tank
loser bracket so you know we're not
going to go straight into the top cape
we can have some hors d'oeuvres first
you know we were talking about this
before the volleyball ones the you know
the little finger through the starters
you know because you know you can't just
go straight into a main course you need
to have you know the wings first or a
little thing you know a little taster i
do like i'm a foodie myself i do like
that kind of stuff
yeah yeah yeah you have to get the
little chicken wings and the the spring
the spring rolls and all that
you know you're making me
scream wait what did they eat in the
middle east as uh for starters uh i feel
bad because we went to the middle east
those little like lamb mince kebabs what
they call them though um the uh what
lamb kebabs yeah which one you know that
one's just like minced meat it's like
quite a lot of flavors and spices in it
it's like coffee or something like that
yeah yeah yeah but i don't know if
that's their starters or not but making
me hungry but i haven't eaten
yeah yeah but either way ladies lads
thank you for tuning in please share the
stream let everyone know what's going on
here toc 2021 middle east um again you
know when you i want to stress the fact
that you know what so many times in um
i've seen like top players from the
middle east and other games complained
that they haven't been represented uh
when it comes to these major tours but
from you know from 2019
having a master event in the middle east
was such a massive step towards allowing
that region to get representation and to
put themselves on the map we saw some
players break onto the scene there that
we hadn't seen before right and it gave
other other players opportunities to
actually just compete in a in a big
event and that's the that's what i feel
like tekken was leading the way forward
when it comes to this to this stuff and
now we have a middle east online event
where certain players who weren't able
to travel from that region will be able
to compete here today right to show what
they're made of and who knows man i mean
i think if they're able to get the win
here today then it's going to put them
on the map and they might be able to
even compete offline man yeah it's going
to be a stronger standing for them to
make it you know to to the finals but
talking about we got the next well i
guess the next game up we're going to
have m7
cafe
so
jordan versus saudi arabia here to start
it off and then coming up after that is
going to be solid stone from israel the
dragon of player going up against
another jordanian player muhammad
mishima uh again from uh from jordan so
these are players that i was able to see
when i went to
what yes i know yeah yeah so um i was
able to see these players play when uh i
went to jordan and man they were very
strong the uh to the the fake
invitational that happened in jordan we
had koreans like puma knee osan the
pakistanis like
and uh was it was there any more person
i don't know but either way those
jordanian players were like putting up a
really good fight one of them even beat
eye musician at the tournament so like
these guys are no joke at all and we're
starting up here ladies and gents here
we go
versus bk don't let that first stand for
you i've played this guy he's very very
strong with that gigas man he knows his
character inside out this is a top eight
qualifier ladies let's let's get it man
devil's pit started off yes so we're
going to see gigas i've been seeing a
lot more of kickass recently you know
we've seen the
is a character which i believe like kind
of early on in tekken wasn't the best
character right but you know got the
buffs that made his damage really really
crazy look at that man crazy damage and
i you know what i'm going to put it out
there i said that gigas i remember i
said it from the moment yeah i had a
feeling it had a sneak peek obviously
he's received
you know the the i guess the buffs
which is made yeah a lot more viable but
you know i've always believed in this
character
yeah yeah i mean you said from the start
that you know his simplicity is what
makes him really strong right if you
have solid fundamentals but they've also
just buffed his fundamental tools in
general if you're not breaking that
through it's gonna hurt man this is not
a great start nice
okay let's see okay guess the side step
two
okay nice conversion take some off the
wall there
okay
block on this down one plus two
we're gonna okay interesting
no oh my god yes that is low carrier
ball the second hit
yeah i'm going to go to a wall stage now
yeah we're transitioning here now my
good start here for bk he's really
showing what he's made of and he's using
a lot of that headbutt just in case
asaka tries to go for a parry reverse or
something yes exactly yes that's not
really low parried i mean
getting parried yeah
he loves to use that help kick man i've
never actually seen him oh my god what's
going on what's going on what he's going
what's he doing okay oh gets the jab i
guess it's best for him not to get hit
by anything big man
i think he's dead
oh my god tremendous damage baby tantrum
yeah that lasted doing so much that was
a quick game bubsy that was um
do you think that's that match up
unfamiliarly
unfamiliarity i am very bad with words
this morning i don't i don't think so
bro i just think he played really well
there i mean you can see the low parry
on the down back four string you can see
the the way he was applying pressure
with back one plus two the plus frame
head but um he wasn't breaking the
throws either you don't break that one
plus two throughout the wall and that's
good that's hard almost half your health
man so definitely gotta wake up here man
i know it's a lot of pressure it's loser
bracket action bk was put into the loser
bracket by complain from israel so um
he's here battling for that top eight
loser's side um it's a lot of stress
bubsy and of course like we mentioned
just before this match like middle east
hasn't had these kind of big
opportunities to play on the big stage
before it's on stream now official
channel a lot of people watching you
know like it's stress yeah it's
definitely that's one of the things that
people don't we've said i think i've
said this many times before like when
you get into these tournament situations
it's it's not the same as you know
playing like me and you playing casually
there's a there's added pressure that
you know you need to win and some
players may not be used to that pressure
and it could really affect your gameplay
stuff that you know oh yeah i know this
move and after i can react to it just
when you put under that little bit of
pressure
it can all go out the window mate yeah
absolutely man so we're going to the
abandoned temple now a stage switch here
for rafael he's going to stick with the
asaka you see that he's got the tgp he
may not be showing exactly what he's
made of here because bk just really
didn't let him get anything started um
so it's time for him to kind of you know
start to apply the pressure a little bit
more here versus bk don't let bk do what
he wants to do yeah they say sometimes a
great offense is a it's a good defense
so
maybe that's the way to go forward now
just so pure offense
absolutely there we go this is a good
better spot this is that's something
not letting bk do what he wants to do
okay okay now he's breaking the throne
that's nice
yep
oh my god i've never seen
kickers just use that hot kick i don't
even know he had that
yeah it's literally just up for four oh
my god look at this
bk
it works
oh my word bk put it on the performance
here right now
pressure and tournaments and when these
things rock you something like that
would rock you know you need to see is
the fear can really have that mental
compulsion to come back from that
yeah 100 like that's not looking good
and he's got to take a mix up now oh
okay nice intelligent yeah okay
nice okay nice pun it's a huge chunk of
damage here what's that okay does that
mean okay yeah oh big whiff yeah that
could be punished oh gosh back against
the wall again i guess the unblockable
this time big wool combo
yeah oh
i'll go through the countdown try to get
a car hit there
yeah
oh
nice and this should be the round i
don't want to jinx it yeah yeah nice
kept the combo simple better down back
one two tail spin not gonna drop that
one rafael finally on the board now yeah
that was that's a big round also what
happened in the previous round with all
the those jumping stomps from gigas it's
a statement he needs to get his foot in
this match right now
yeah yeah
don't let him do that here okay nice
back to me you know that ask a special
there
big bone blockable of his own okay
okay okay
again breaking the throne now this is
really good stuff oh
just come just goes for it anyway no
breaking the normal throw
yeah he dropped the cover that was a
game winning combo as well if he loses
this one it's not gonna be good for his
confidence again now going for that plus
frames rage available okay nice block
but no punish that could have been
around he's got that punch but never met
oh gosh here we go the blue stuff
guaranteed yeah guaranteed stuff there
now oh graphic don't lose this one man
you had it oh no the wall saved his life
was he gonna do that oh no
that is rough what a heartbreaker no
break on the throw again now set point
for bk to eliminate harford and move
into top eight here for the loser side
and that was a great example of pressure
there like he was breaking those throats
previously but when his life was low and
it mattered that pressure came they
can't
[Music]
[Music]
yeah what a good combo they're using the
rage drive for that big damage gotham
now one round away from even to get up
yeah what a big nice stroll break there
yeah it's crucial
he gets floated okay doesn't get the
full conversion oh big whiff in the back
no in the back where's the kanjans
okay well you got something car of it
yeah nothing
definitely could have got more though no
punishment that's punishable there
could have confirmed that all the way
nice little eyes it's gonna go through
the wall okay nope
just a bit shy all right what's the mix
up now go to the mid nice block in the
mid
yep
three punish there
i'm sure down two would probably beat
every option but if we go get the punch
there goes the unblockable guess what i
think he could have done combo there he
could have killed he probably wouldn't
cut the combo but he drops it bk now
gonna go for the ray job that is gonna
hit crazy crazy damage incoming after
now with rage it's gonna come up to one
more mix-up who is gonna take it
he's key charging
oh gosh i'm scared i am really scared
what's gonna happen oh about three plus
frames and the down forward four to
finish it off bk is gonna take it two oh
raphael almost brought it back but yeah
man that was a couple two one too many
drops therefore after man i don't know
if it was a stress or what but bk good
composure he takes it it was really
unfortunate because he said that he had
the unblockable and he got the wall
splat and i think he could have dashed
up down the back four wall combo because
i think that hits low enough and that
that would have been the round i'm i'm
i'm almost sure of it because that does
a lot of damage
whatever yeah yeah three room circuits
would have hit as well because it starts
with the lower it does it's quite low i
just i think that you know even i when i
saw that i was like is it going to work
is it not going to work it was like
in that situation where there's a lot of
stress you often think that maybe let me
go for the safe option and not try to
because we tried to drop the combo yeah
yeah that could have been a good shot
because if he went for it and he tacked
could have been the end there so
actually don't you know what it's one of
those would have should have could have
been you don't know yeah
yeah but all good a great way to start
off the the the match here for the the
online challenge middle east master
event man that gigas again like you said
not not a character you see often but
we've been seeing them do a lot of work
in the icf series
up in asia man like always got like one
of the gig asses from asia in that top
three somehow i mean it's just amazing
to see and and this bk again when i was
playing kick ass i i really wanted to
learn the character and he was in my
chat helping me to learn the character
man so again this guy has knowledge of
the class i've been playing him since
the very beginning and he's in top eight
now top eight for the middle east master
yes definitely congratulations to him
and then our next match is going to be
um
solid stone from israel going up against
muhammad mishima from jordan so israel
versus jordan here is that solid stone
is a play that we've known for a very
long time he's a dragon of maine uh i
don't think i've ever seen the guy play
many other characters
ryan i want to say i've seen him play
brian but those two kind of go together
hand in hand i'm sure if you played tag
two you would have played a little bit
of brian i wonder who is he going to
pick next i haven't seen him play for a
while but he was considered for a very
long time to be the best player in
israel i don't know if that's still the
case
but it's gonna go with the dragon of of
course and uh on the side of muhammad
mishima from jordan going with the ling
is this is this one of those things now
where you're like if you have a name
like real gin player 101 you just play
someone else
but it's like an unwritten rule if you
have a character name in your
in your as your tag you just never play
like you know i am just
101. who do you play
dango jin like all these people with gin
in their names look at this look at this
look at these uh
graphics they were the stage one of the
most pretty stages in the game here we
go israel versus jordan let's get it
so we know dragon off
he's been the character has kind of gone
up and down like at a start in season
one he was extremely strong then he got
a couple normalizations we should say
yeah down two but i think now he's he's
like a
very well-rounded nice pirate okay this
is a big war break
yeah i don't know why he delayed that
string he delayed the last hit of that
down back to string and then allowed
mohammed mishma to
to go for the parry
i don't know
yeah oh was that a rage drive attempt
yeah i think you know he wanted to go
for that for that move because it gives
him a free range drive no brake on the
throttle that's huge damage
oh standing for this clips
are you trying to come in and that's the
first round on the board for solid stone
yeah box let's talk about this you know
throw breaking in second seven like
what's going on here well i mean i feel
like a lot of people that i mean maybe
started in c7 that throwback and ain't
the best sign
i don't know um
i know that your thought breaking was
amazing in tact too like that was way
harder like way harder for us have you
gotten that this should be the right oh
no actually no commentators still get
the seven golden letters but from
working as it's for people that don't
know so for generic froze um with the
one and two you can rate them either or
but when you get to the um command
throws you actually have to look at the
arms there
so he puts out his left arm first you
press one or square one and then
triangle for the opposite arm
yeah so that might be a big uh a big
thing here for this match-up we saw that
he didn't break the throw so let's see
if uh solid stone can get some throws
again
you said it right there it happened
again and that yeah you've got to be
breaking those throws man
that is definitely a command pro nice
patience there blocking nice sidestep
launcher
hmm go for a simple combo won't reach
the wall
okay nice stays down down two and just
go
keeping it nice and clean round four
yeah very very good stuff here muhammad
see what he's gonna do to answer back
that down back to string that damage is
low but uh is very very strong you know
ling got it recently a high crushing um
plus on hit and it's even safer to
certain characters as well so i want to
see him go for those lows a bit more
yeah i mean if you've got a move it's
such good you know properties and you
know you need to abuse it and use it
yeah there it is
[Music]
oh that was sick
i know trying to go for the wall break
there you have the middle of the mid
again but it doesn't commit but the
throw ladies are allowed we're going to
a final round again
solid stone versus muhammad mishima i
love that pressure against the wall just
did not let sully stone like gabriel's
swords and again the one throw he's not
breaking though solid stone probably
he's definitely recognized that now and
you've seen that that's a way to get
some free damage here
yeah
i think at least with ling you know one
thing that she can do is you know crush
those but talking about throws not a
stone not breaking throws either
this could be the normal tournament
nerves and pressure that could have been
launched there
that's scary aop is so scary sometimes
it may be your turn but it's just going
to evade
oh oh no
is that going to be it yes it is the low
from muhammad mishima and he's going to
take the first game head versus solid
stone one of the best players in israel
but we took we can take a lot of
information from that bubsy i mean both
guys weren't breaking throws um
we saw muhammad mishima started going
with the lows a little bit more because
wasn't blocking them but yeah the the
ling from he has good setups man like
it's it's a dangerous character now
definitely when he's back turned um
it seems like uh solid stone he thinks
okay this is my turn to press the button
so many times he's gone for those
parries and it's worked and
this is one of the things with paris
that people don't understand you it
could be the opponent's turn you could
think you know this is my turn it's my
turn to press the button and then you
get parried and then later on you can
put in that same situation and and it
often gives you a mind mess it messes
your mind you're thinking i know it's my
turn
but do i press no is he going to pass
yeah and it has that next kind of level
of mind game that goes on so it'll be
interesting to see what he does going
forward when ling's in back turn
yeah yeah for sure we've got to see the
we've got to see mohamed and misha start
to break those throws but like i said
that ling has the options she's a very
evasive character might be able to go
for aop uh and some other evasive moves
to go under the throws so maybe that's
something that he's going to be thinking
about as well but sticking with the
dragon oven going to the island paradise
now it is still first or two and this is
loser bracket action to make it into top
eight so all to play for right now here
muhammad mishima up 1-0 from jordan and
you know jordan we'll talk about it a
bit later on but like that scene very
small but very very committed and
passionate and strong
as we say that though look at this
island paradise beautiful yeah
the graphics here one of my favorite
stages now yeah let's get into the
editions right
one of the new dlc stages
yeah
okay
just gotta go downstairs now we're going
to the beach guys
okay it's going to carry towards the
wall
nice setup
okay just down oh okay straight out of
the bat there we go
combo no
combo but so fortunate there to evade
does it have rage available all right
uses it defends it
no nice dark and the dial 4 keeps it
simple mohammed mission with all the
momentum right now definitely solid
stone needs to break this momentum but
not like that it just seems like
mohammed has the answer there with a
great little parry
oh nice
cheeky little right there to get a read
okay and i think uh somebody was telling
me actually that i decided in paradise
um when you go downstairs it's one of
the biggest stages in the game so
finding the wall is actually going to be
pretty tough depending on where you are
because normally with that dragon
offender um
we get to the walls we definitely get
the balls there that's actually quite
surprised
yeah nice little adaptation on the combo
oh that was a great conversion they're
very aware oh no be accounted and this
should be my job
yeah yeah
mohammed mishima is gonna be on set
point now ladies and gents to eliminate
solid stone from the tournament is he
gonna be able to make top eight here
yeah that is very unfortunate they're
just going in a little bit too heavy
getting can't hit um on the get up kick
there
okay one falls now we've seen them come
back out he's not breaking those at all
yeah the throat breaking is definitely a
weakness of his right now
but he's still battling still going
through hitting wind with the lows to
keep out oh okay spring kick in the back
frames i guess i can't hit four
yeah but he he got the forward three
instead of standing three for the tail
spin unfortunately drops a combo
all right
again again this is very interesting so
he's not using his plus frames though
he's getting count himself
again oh my god three times in a row
using magic four after blocking back one
plus two just being on minus what a read
and this is fuzzy
this is the thing when
so when you realize sometimes when
you're playing fighting games you need
to like kind of see what's going on in
it this happened once and twice he
should have known to probably you know
what i need to make this guy respect my
friend yeah you're gonna have to respect
me put some respect on my name on my
back one plus two respect it but
i guess it was a great read he had to
read he knew what was going on he knew
what was going on what did he do
i don't know what he would have done
three times in a row so like obviously
after the second time it's like
okay after the last one he went for the
rage right yeah he did backwards
drive but yeah man you should have known
i guess the no mix up mix up right it's
nice
paper roll scissors i'm gonna pick
paper yeah yeah
but yeah uh good stuff there for
muhammad mishima from jordan he will
move into top eight as well but
eliminating one of the best players in
uh in israel
uh solid solid stuff there no pun
intended yeah i like that one
but yeah definitely a solid start here
for the
middle east guys
thank you for tuning in everybody is we
have we this is still not even top eight
we're just looking at the top eight
followers
we're in the rings at the minute now
we're still in the orders you know
coming in
yeah yeah the main course is yet to come
and there's players waiting up there man
you guys definitely want to keep an eye
on there's people that have beaten the
best players in the world in these
master events oh i'm looking forward to
it i believe yeah
yeah absolutely but yeah uh here we go
guys check out the uh
the master events here these uh right
now we're what you're watching the
middle east um but there are so many
more yet to come yesterday we had south
africa south africa of course um
was it was quite unique as well we saw
players that we haven't really seen
before that are very very strong and
there's many more to come as well oceana
region philippines east asia southeast
asia these are these are regions we
don't really get to see a lot uh there's
countries that are going to be
represented which i know have very very
strong players that we have that um
people are going to be very surprised
about for sure
yeah i mean this look at this this is a
world tour just just look at all the
different regions it's actually
beautiful to see how tekken has actually
just brought everyone together and it's
it's a great thing to see
yeah well we did we did all the
traveling man so everything we've seen
how crazy it is but ladies and gentle
must make sure that if you are part of
the uh tekken online challenge that you
follow that link on screen right now and
you register to be part of the
leaderboard because if you win a master
event if you win these dojo events and
you're not registered then those points
are not going to count towards your name
and there's already been cases of people
not registering but winning and doing
really well in tournaments so they
haven't been able to to get onto the
leaderboard so if you are interested in
competing no matter where you are around
the world make sure that you um that you
follow that link and you register and of
course if you guys are tourma organizers
out there and you're interested to make
an online dojo event um which will allow
people to compete and earn points for
your event then those applications will
end on october 10th so uh if you guys
have your events and you're interested
to be part of the tour then make sure
that you get your application in a s
maybe yes you know 10th of october that
is not far from now so less than a month
away
yeah definitely man and those dojo
events man they've been uh
a godsend
they've been they've been the game
changer definitely 100 have been a game
changer for since they were introduced
it's been beautiful because obviously
you get to see
even more of these players and these
guys it may not be able to come out they
get to at least have a chance to shine
and yeah be a part of this world tour
you know yeah yeah
insha allah guys inshallah let's go so
we cut a
from saudi arabia
going up against hunch from jordan again
like the jordans have come in quite
heavy here for for this tournament uh
and rife you know i've i've
i think i might have played him but i've
definitely seen him playing this guy is
a like a legit gin they have so many
strong gin players in saudi arabia if
there was one character that i feel
would represent that that's that region
it's definitely jin yeah i think jin is
a solid character i mean why not i think
he's great he's got he's i think he's
got tools for everything basically he's
got parry you know he's got the
electrics ford four you know the the
daddy long foot it's all there
yeah
we're talking about lane i don't know
why but like people kind of sleeping on
him a little bit here and there man like
we haven't been hearing him about much
about him but he's a very complete
character right yeah i i i totally 100
agree especially that new addition now
he's got that wall carry and the wall
come on now to get that flip over that's
huge damage but no walls here
oh nice just get yourself off the ground
lay once lane starts going into stances
like that with rage drive available all
right mix up city bro you just don't
want to guess
100
oh nice oh we actually tried to go for
the homie move there but managed to go
underneath it nice here we go hunty
getting something started here we go
okay i like that okay see again so he's
opted to go for he just doesn't want to
he's like i'm going to get airborne i do
not want to deal with this mixer i am
not getting put in this blender he's
jumping out of the blender in a minute
crispy
all right here we go nice does it just
just outside the rage here goes for the
hell sweep the jahannam sweep
and have you gone big damage no
last chance to lose okay this is clutch
get off me ufc
again again he's going for that
i wonder if hunch is gonna is gonna like
react to this
nice start you didn't let it rip but but
um yeah was definitely ready for that
nice light here again
that's the thing blake you kind of have
to kind of know what to do when he's in
stances i i say it as easy as i i'm
still a bit confused when he does this
stuff
oh my god
nice four four three so
again you know lay a character as one
that got buffed in this recent season
and you know not a lot of people know
how to play against it because of all
the different options he has right so if
you're not ready for him then someone
like hunt is definitely going to take
you out yeah that's what i'm saying so
mixed up heavy once he gets in that
stuff let me see race does not want to
deal with that stance but it's got a
good start here
nice uses the 4 4 4 to catch him on the
ground
that's one thing i think people really
sleep on late like they run up and try
to attack him like it's a meat attack
and they will get lost when he's on the
ground he does have moves
there's a lovely lovely duck down the
string nice they're nice look at this
pressure
yeah
something better than nothing here we go
that's 50 off now from the rife what can
a hunch do here
can you finish it okay
nice so he's using that i think r42 just
to turn the side step a bit
okay nice full oh okay it goes to the
health soup again it's gonna put him in
rage though so there's gonna be big mix
up city if you get some stuff nice it
goes down to there
actually i even forgot about that when i
saw that oh yeah he has that as well
he's got jab blows he's got good jab
strings this this character is complete
he is very complete man and with with
solid fundamentals in the right hands is
a character that can do big damage we
all know and i feel like a lot of people
in the chat were actually asking as well
where is sora you know sora from saudi
arabia you know sitting cross-legged on
his uh on the chair playing with uh
playing on pad with that gin you know
he's beat up so many people it was very
top top player with with jin up in uh in
saudi arabia he's not going to be here
today but
trying to do trying to do the thing here
today and uh
yeah like clearly you can see that
there's some a match of unfamiliarity
when it comes to lay but he did a really
good job in using the right moves to
mitigate the damage definitely that the
hunch could do against definitely that
um
there's that spin and will kick i'm
gonna call it i can't remember just
literally getting off the ground he
knows if he gets caught he's gonna be
floating there's gonna be less damage
um he's yeah he just doesn't want to
deal with it i i i totally agree with it
because once you're in that smith shop
blender especially with like i said
before when he has rage and he's got um
access to more moves that do more damage
yeah you know i i'm going to take the
airborne here all day all day i respect
absolutely like and if you if you do
that that move and you end up on the
floor i mean you can see that how many
times did uh
did hunch just go through a down four
there's not much you can do like uh he
hasn't got like a heihachi four four two
or
or like a a i don't know a ford forward
four to flip you over right so you know
that in that situation me to get the
damage and not much they can do
definitely definitely so i wonder if
there's gonna be like a character change
maybe it'll be interesting because
anyway actually it wasn't that bad it
was it was back and forth it was back
and forth it was three two two rounds i
wonder i think maybe a stage pick
because if he's locked down against the
wall i think that's one of the things
when you play against um lei what i tend
to do is just back off i don't i don't
really want to deal with it
but then when you're backed against the
wall
shmix up time in it
absolutely but he's sticking with the
lay here we're going to violet systems
okay so the walls are still in well not
sitting in place walls are in play now
we've got an infinite stage for the
first one uh rife was able to do a good
job there was very close but let's see
what they can do now with the walls in
play have you gone very very interesting
see if you can put him in lockdown in it
there's too much work done man
okay gets the car hit nice conversion is
he gonna find the wall
nice finds the wall
okay obstacle for the doesn't go for the
flip over i respect it keeps him in the
corner look at this pressure this is
deadly he's not letting oh my god
yeah that was
that was rough i mean he chose the walls
this is this is what hunts chose man and
he got himself pointed to the corner and
raped just went to town yeah hey they're
going to hunch now answering back
say it's a double-edged sword sometimes
sometimes you live by the world you can
die by it man that's how it goes
sometimes and again he's just mourning
him he's not letting him get anything
started and i agree with this but as i
say that he's he got tired
yeah okay big counter here
he's got rage available as well oh he's
trying to go some cheeky stuff there
close the line there he went for a parry
there see we went for a big mid or
something
unfortunate there
not gonna work have you got one round a
piece i like it this match very back and
forth nice
it doesn't cut the second hit of that
demon or no they're not team poor these
are scrapers i'm getting my names mixed
up
we're starting to see a lot more parries
here now bubsy and this is working out
for him hunch gets a wall for that big
damage
there we go okay nice start he knows
that string has a high extension and big
electric just takes it out ray's looking
really strong now
yeah he moves on to set point yeah he
seems like he's really um just he's just
smalling him down he's showing his um
his aggression really
yeah
he's choosing his shots you can see the
movement some point finally blocks one
of the johannam sleeps and we got hunch
now gonna get a big combo goes for the
oaky instead okay nice stays grounded
doesn't want to have anything to do with
that again he's gonna get the wall that
flip okay what's the mix up
nice nice
there again but i think maybe the frames
are just two plus they look like right
yeah
all right have we got another
final round here two final rounds in a
row nice punish
oh
he's in the blame for the pressure here
bob you look at the pressure no [ __ ]
nice using the power there to alleviate
the pressure
there you go get the launch
you're definitely going to find the wall
here
okay
oh no oh because the walls
available for hunch oh my god what's
happening
oh
no
that was a that was a clutch block
that was a very clutch block
you tried to send him to johannes
i do my five prayers a day bro get out
of here nice beautiful stuff there from
rafe going to get the win 2-0 but it was
two final rounds uh commiseration is the
hunch of course for not making it to the
top eight but that was a very good
performance got a ninth place finishing
so i believe he might get some he will
be getting some points um on the on the
leaderboard it's a master event so i'm
assuming he will get some points we'll
figure it out
yeah
but yeah nice uh rife so that's another
saudi arabian um
saudi arabia now moving into safe i
believe that was loser bracket action as
well guys so we haven't even seen who's
in winners right now but the the bracket
is live i could tell you actually uh
looking at the bracket that there are
some saudis in top eight uh luffy the
person who beat ursuline ash yeah you
know
at the uh offline i believe you can get
the brackets
let's have a look yes we can show you
guys right uh there it all look at that
okay so md luffy versus complain the
complaint is the person who put our our
boy bk the gigas player in losers so
luffy versus complaining israel to saudi
arabia and then on the other side we've
got devil rocky from saudi arabia going
up against ultra instinct potato
an icfc champion uh for one of the weeks
from georgia and this guy's been doing a
big work in these online tournaments
we're using that king yes i'm i'm i'm a
fan of king so i'm actually i'm looking
forward to all these game matches i'm
looking actually one of the people i'm
looking forward to
seeing players complain definitely
complain that's going to be my my watch
yeah that's that's one of the players
that we've been we've been playing
against since tekken tag two you know
like he's been using that yoshimitsu uh
since then i think his main team back in
tag two was feng and and yoshi so if the
yoshi really doesn't work out then feng
you know with how feng is in season four
bro like strong character yeah yeah fang
i think is definitely one of those
characters that really slept on really
really slept on but i'm saying complain
i actually saw him use paul this week i
saw him actually play one of our own um
kanan trench and it was it was a death
match online and his paw was
putting in work and kanan trench is no
slouch and he was using that pool so
yeah maybe maybe paul is definitely a
tournament character he he will delete
your life bar before
that especially with luffy you know like
some people use paul as like a secondary
character that they use you know just on
the side for certain matchups now luffy
is a poor mane and those guys are scary
we've seen this guy's been able to be
the best players in the world i
personally want to see luffy travel
around when when uh tweet comes back
when offline returns you know i want to
see luffy like start to travel i want
someone to pick this guy up as a sponsor
and just like you know he's such an
entertaining pool player to watch and
fundamentally solid right yeah uh on the
other side with devil rocky versus ultra
into potato potato using king but you
know i think saudi arabia has a lot of
experience versus king not only federer
not only kayal but i think other people
also have kings in saudi arabia so i
think the the matchup knowledge will be
there so i'm super excited for the
winner semi-finals which will be coming
up a little bit later um but we still
have to decide and see who is going to
be making it into the
loser side of the top eight we have bk
and reif uh two saudis going up against
each other in the loser's side and
muhammad mishima from jordan and we're
still going to be waiting to see who is
making it into the last position for top
eight um but it's been a great great
start here yes so we're gonna
like say fill out this last spot so we
can finalize the top eight for you guys
like i said this is just the entree
the main course is yet to come and it's
gonna be a juicy top 8 definitely going
to be a juicy topic we're going to see
many high level games you should be had
a little taster these games are great um
they're getting me excited they say we
went through the winners and side and as
i was speaking about complaining i'm
looking forward to complain but
yeah you know it's going to be an
entertaining bracket i can tell you that
it will so diverse as well which is what
you would love to see right you want to
see diversity here but ladies and gents
this is the final top eight qualifier
it's gonna be a nice one we have masood
you guys were asking for it versus
hampnon
from israel
managed to make it all the way here and
he's one match away from making this
topic we're going to the forgotten realm
so it's party time i want to see you
guys get a little bit loud in the chat
man this is what you're waiting for man
why you guys so quiet massoud with the
kazoo going up against hampden with the
murdoch yes and my dog is is one of
those characters i
he he's a powerhouse let's just say that
he he hits like a truck especially when
he gets to the wall and he's got that 50
50 throw
with the wool combo
50 50. he's not going to guess right all
the time mate you know absolutely oh
nice start there going for the the
electric
we're going downstairs
okay oh hell sweet if you're gonna go
downstairs again
oh okay just right as we are this is um
very offensive low parry
is he gonna break the final floor we're
downstairs
it's only been 20 seconds
we need to get the records out like i'm
sure it was a guinness record i've never
seen i've never seen him get to the
bottom floor i think
that was record time
that's real time bro what the hell bro
like
sorry like 18 seconds guys
18.67 seconds man
lovely
nice healthy okay scout that one out but
doesn't get the punish unfortunate there
yeah it's all over him right now stuck
to him like glue not letting him do
anything no duck on the string but seven
golden letters have gone on the back
foot now he's definitely on the back
foot
he needs to just break this okay nice
well that could give him some confidence
you know gets a little parry okay i
respect him man i respect it he's
treating him like he's a casual he's not
hamlet never heard of you bro oh if you
want to do it again yeah do it tim do it
if you can hit it you're a gangster do
it that can't hit launches oh nice with
punish
people didn't believe me that upward
four can't hit launches you know
that's embarrassing if i get hit by that
i think the first move you learn when
you're going power slam
down and pound nice reaction there
spring kicks
rage is available he spends it nice the
power crusher great option
yeah
very good usage of that power crush not
not not a power questions aren't used a
lot by certain individuals so you still
kind of get caught off guard sometimes
definitely that's good it adds another
layer to the game where if someone uses
it you're like okay it may be my turn
but
i'm talking about this this is classic
kazuya stuff right here man the vortex
the 5050s the coin flips and he's
guessing wrong every single time hamlet
with rage now can he make the comeback
a frackie okay one plus two fro this
could be the start of something but okay
is the wall going to mess him up though
no it doesn't okay oh oh oh oh
he could have done a madness there he
texted his back towards mars if he read
that uh down was it downforce free in
the back
yeah
i think there's a lot of things you
could have done that i've seen sometimes
with okizami because monarch has the
best oak in the game i'm pretty sure
that ma like has the best work in the
game right yeah he's one of the best
yeah but i just feel like i would say
right now the best
uh and from what i've seen like there's
certain players that haven't been on
stream that we haven't seen compete that
i know like john from ireland his okie
is ridiculous with he just knows
everything man like it's so oppressive
but even then that situation he could
have gone for the back throw and mark's
black throw is dirt damage you know he
holds him back and he like does
something he jumps yeah yeah yeah it's
mad bro like so yeah i dropped
opportunity there from hamptonon
playing with with no fear at all no
right there's no nerves you don't he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's going for the
upward four four he's he's he's loving
life he's running the he he ran the
like the mix up the vortex he said you
know what you are playing my game we're
not playing tekken 7 no no no you're
playing my game bro you're playing
massoud seven
but yeah uh this is the final uh top
eight qualifier now is it gonna be
another saudi arabian or are we going to
get an israeli in there i feel like
hampden will probably switch away from
marduk now seeing that it was was it was
three rounds straight right or maybe
round straight with a record
so maybe go to the geese because the
geese is the character that he also uses
he uses geese and marduk um the geese
might have to be the character he goes
for him the goose may be on the loose
what do you think uh compared to
tomorrow i i
well
it
yeah i'm gonna say it was kind of i
don't wanna sound cruel but it was it
looked kind of one-sided it looked like
he was just getting game run on him like
like i said he was just he didn't really
have a foot in i reckon if he got that
round with where he had the weird wool
tech and he managed to get the back
floor and get something started then
maybe but it felt like he was literally
just increasing his vortex and i feel
i feel like geese especially with the um
he's got the down kind of jabs in it
that can can't hit so i feel obviously
with the electrics come in night and
with a healthy you can kind of interrupt
it as well
because it has a slower startup i feel
that maybe geese and geese is a strong
character we've seen what geese can do
so yeah yeah i feel like with with uh
commander compared to
compared to geese i feel like he's
having that down forward one the generic
downford one a very strong one as well
yeah just to kind of and the jab man the
2d jabs with you know geese's jab is
super strong um using that as just keep
out yeah because masood is very
aggressive
but yeah keep out key part is what i
feel he liked that much because it
looked like once he got the hell
sweeping
and he was in that vortex he couldn't
keep him out it was just like you know
everyone come in free-fall
yeah so like having having the jab
having the downfall one having these
things that can keep your opponent away
from you uh when they try to run into it
because masood are playing extremely
aggressive yeah that much so um having
geese might help her he might just go
straight back for mata and just use a
bit more damage too there's options that
he can do to kind of counter here and
keep out the the kazuya but a geese
howard might be the pick here either way
guys let's see let's uh let's go let's
see
oh he he he just
um oh for a spanner
i didn't know this one
rubble hamlon does play like pretty much
every character in the game like uh
whenever i'm streaming and i need to and
i'm picking up a new character there's
one person i know that will tell me the
the optimal combos and his hammer on
he'll be like well this is the comma for
this and i'm like how do you know every
combo with every character the guy loves
second he plays this game but i don't
know why he's going for safina i feel
like kazuya has good options to beat
sabine because her main low down three
is launched punishable versus character
but let's see man maybe massoud will not
know the match up as well and he can get
something inside here oh gets a big
count at the beginning yeah convert off
a bit though nice oh my days yeah he's
just
it just seems that masseuse just in his
head just so much aggression okay nice
block in the hell sweep get something
started now
okay get
yep delay for the max damage
okay we've got mr backing up now that
that could be a telltale sign didn't jab
in between that oh god
and that's the thing about kazoo man
even if you don't get that you don't
have the best punishment you just gotta
guess right a couple times but that's a
huge whiff
easy punish she didn't even back that
she just held back and walked back that
was a yeah bit of a panic rage drive i
feel there just needs to gain some
composure again
yeah
he did have a good showing in that last
round oh no he's he's got him he's in
his head this is rent free he's on the
inside of his head
that was two lows in the mid the classic
nice okay the blocks are down three but
no punish there from massoud uh of
course um having those while they want
to the 30 frame launcher you can launch
that low yeah but i feel like we just
got a broad head bobby it's just a brawl
it is yeah it's history miss who just
wants to fight and do what he's doing it
seems like hamdan has to just kind of
defend oh no oh he pressed the button
bubsy
don't do the rage on the suit
just clutching it out every single time
not letting hamlet get anything started
on set points and move to the top now
every
it just seems that massoud just has the
answer just to stop it in his tracks and
there's literally just stopped him
there we go
oh why are you ducking i want to see ham
probably utilize more sidestep left in
this match
i think that's that's one of the things
mainly because satellite does um well
when it's time properly that's beat both
of these brazilian moves that he's using
ah
an interesting choice to go for zafina
in the end i don't know what his game
plan was but
massoud just didn't let him get anything
started just uh got into his head and
played very unpredictable and aggressive
and i think that you know if there's if
the other if the opponent is going to
play uh
like nervous at all yeah someone like
masood is going to take you up because
that guy was not nervous he just did his
thing he was enjoying life i think one
of the scariest things is uh is a
mishima that's coming at you
100 miles an hour i think that's one of
the scariest things i remember
playing shout outs to cyrus i haven't
heard that name in ages playing syrups
from ages ago he is one of those
missions that are on 100 miles an hour
and once they get going
it is sometimes it's just hard to stop
and as you saw there even when hamline
did get something going
he he just had the answer and just
stopped his momentum straight away and
just like not my turn again you're
playing my game
so yeah unfortunately i'm sure i'm sure
that the connection was a five bar as
well so shout outs to masood you know a
very uh very good match with no lag at
all so
yeah
uh you know 100 deserved and makes it
into top eight there another saudi
arabian in uh top eight beautiful stuff
here's a look at the bracket um we've
got so many saudis and we did say that
uh saudis were um
were the were the favorites to win here
today but we do have a diverse uh pool
here still with uh with jordan uh
georgia and israel represented
it's gonna be interesting we've got five
saudis yeah so the majority the
favorites to win probably about numbers
yeah
but yeah i'm really looking forward to
to see the top eight now guys like you
said bubsy the main course is coming up
yes the main courses come this was just
the start start there's sunday dinners
coming up it's sunday out here you know
you could go for a nice sunday roast
myself i'll do last time yeah but who
would you say is your favorite to uh to
win
is he putting me on the spot here and
the questions i'll say right now okay
who's your favorite
uh for luffy luffy's gotta be my
favorite to win this one man okay yeah
that paul w seen it before is that
paul's very strong he said paul maine's
scary manes um okay i'm gonna have to
throw it up a bit then i i want i want
to see complain i love a yoshimitsu when
he when when yoshimitsu get going i want
to see some madness i want to see some
craziness uh you know that's going to be
my pick you know i can't we you know
keep it interesting it'll be interesting
yeah um okay cool i like that uh but the
loads of saudis uh here again like you
said that this is a community community
has seen that i really want to travel
too i haven't yet i haven't been to
saudi arabia
i've been there but i've been there for
like you know
there's so many killers that we haven't
even that didn't even enter today those
people like fedra sword and these guys i
didn't even enter but the extreme
extremely song but we do have uh some of
the best players represented here in
this topic that is that so yeah
definitely definitely can't wait um but
yeah guys make sure as well to uh
to to follow uh
tenno because i have a lot of uh a lot
of good stuff for you guys
check it out i really like this one i'm
gonna have to start whispering some
sweet nothings to someone there yeah i
mean like if you go if you actually
follow 100.gg4 merch you go to the link
you'll see that most of the teachers
actually sold out these ones are back in
stock because these are the most popular
ones if you want to get them get your
hands on them now because they're going
to sell out they're definitely going to
sell out officially licensed tech and
merchandise yeah you can scan the queue
or qr code not qro qr code right there
so if you've got your smartphones out
just go there scan the qr code it takes
you straight to the merch website and
get yourself some of this good ass
tekken merch like i said that king one
was clean that i haven't actually seen
that one and then in the blue as well
yeah i do like a little blue you know
put some nice jeans on with that put
that over your rock and you'll be
looking cool and good i just got my
stamp of approval i like it it's time
for approval there you go nice you got
the boxes of approval that's good man it
ain't easy to get that man and he's
gonna and of course ladies and gentlemen
make sure to follow the social medias
out um the b esports for twitter and
youtube and at tekken for twitter twitch
and facebook if you want to keep up to
date with all what's going on in the
tekken world and for the esports and
then you can you know watch all these
amazing tournaments that we have with
all the gases doing stomps and all the
health sweeps and all that kind of thing
all that jazz six in a row
you know yeah it was sick
all right man um
that is that is those are our top eight
qualifiers that you saw the bracket is
going to be insane i can't wait to see
what happens here because again this is
the first time the middle east has had a
master event online uh we don't we
haven't seen many of these players
compete at the highest level and haven't
even seen them play against each other
so this is gonna be our first time for
the second community here uh we're gonna
take a small break ladies and gentlemen
when we return top eight second online
master middle east action don't go
anywhere yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
enemy warships
arrive to destination
[Music]
enemy reinforcements check your radars
[Music]
fox 2.
[Music]
welcome back guys to the tlc tekken
online challenge for the middle east i
hope you like got refreshed in that
little break got yourself a little drink
you know little snacks because now we
are going to get into the top
eight side of this i am joined by spark
how's it going it's going good man i'm
excited it was a really good uh
i love the qualifiers if that was
anything to go by for what's gonna what
we're gonna have for our top eight i'm
excited man once again guys remember big
shout outs to astro the official headset
and mix amp of the tekken online
challenge 2021 but yes ladies and gents
it is now top eight time you said it
bubsy you know you have the little bit
of kofta you have the spring balls you
have the little you know the tea chicken
then the main thing comes in afterwards
you know the donut meat you know the the
full-on goat bro just the whole goat you
know and with the rice and everything
we're getting the full main meal now
here for the middle east online master
event and we have a lot of saudi
arabians um
uh in in the bracket i think five stars
we have a jordanian we have a georgian
and an israeli so quite diverse actually
yeah we're gonna get the bracket up here
nice so we're gonna have
md luffy who said that's your favorite
actually our favorites are playing first
i don't actually realize that yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah so empty luffy
versus complaint will be our first match
um and then devil rocky versus ultra
instant potato so these are gonna be
great great matches right now ultra
sweet potato is number one on the
leaderboard in the middle east for a
second online challenge so there's all
to play for it and remember guys these
guys haven't got that many points as
well so whoever wins this tournament
will be number one on the leaderboard
for the toc middle east region so
there's so much to play for compared to
like other regions which have had dojo
events like icfcs and stuff to gather
more points but as you can see there it
is winners semi-finals coming up um so
what do you think here uh yoshimitsu vs
paul right that's most likely gonna be
the first match yeah hopefully yeah and
just i'm trying to just think like in my
head what uh matchup knowledge
it could be um i guess you should make
sure with the back two two is that going
to punish defense i know death is such a
um
funny move to punish because
it depends on like the range it hits in
it because if it hits shallow the
pushback is mad it's going to whiff so
it's gonna be that as well and i think
um
paul may have strings also which we you
see in yoshi's can flash in between i
think one of the things he can do and i
saw it actually kane and trench doing
you see the crouch three plus four knee
that sometimes it depending on where it
hits and how it hits that can actually
be flash punished
so it's gonna be interesting to see if
complain has that knowledge to know okay
flash hair you know this is a punishing
even though cats may not get that
punished conventionally yoshi means you
can get the punish
yeah yeah and yoshimura has got some
changes as well like i used to be very
comfortable versus yoshimitsu i remember
that i played kanan trench a lot and i
played him recently as well uh online
because he's come back now and i was
like damn there's a lot of things that i
knew about this character that i didn't
know about before so you know luffy will
have to make sure that he is up to date
with all the stuff and we don't see
yoshimitsu a lot especially with someone
like complain he's been playing for
years and years and years with this
character as well but he's going up
against one of the best players in the
world in md luffy let's go
gonna be very interesting to see okay
nice that's gonna be a guaranteed stab
you cannot break that
um
okay yola it's gonna take him to the
wall okay let's just strap the wall oh
in the back you don't want to get it in
the back
yeah definitely not
all right so luffy hasn't been allowed
to do anything right now going for the
spin to win yeah oh that dish is all
guaranteed
oh
i really like that you went for the
defense there because the wall but no
this is gonna be the round but it was
great awareness there from um
from luffy to go for the difference
because you know getting back turned um
splat into the wall but
yeah and he went for the back one two
and then that was a great duck from
complaints showing that he's on point he
knows the match up yeah he's ready here
to win this tournament man he's on point
he's here for the winner's semi-finals
uh i don't know why he threw out that
back one too but leave him just testing
you know his first or two it was the
first round see what he can get away
with and right now just poking away
oh girls are standing free
i like this space in there
waiting for his opportunity and nice
punish with the look knee
yeah okay again
oh see now with that you kind of need to
wake up all yo she can keep doing that
again and again and again and it will
hit because of the flip over
okay resources have been spent go for
the load no we tried to go through a big
combo there should just gone for the
down two there
and he's dead well i think that the demo
man would have been enough damage to
kill but luffy went for a bit of a
bigger combo didn't work out from
complaining up two rounds now yeah
you're right i forgot yeah demo man does
hit there okay does the demo man there
gets the side kind of moves flat
yep
okay nice sweet
okay big combo i love it
okay man so on point complain right now
he's showing his yoshi knowledge but
lovely hopkins puts him into that he's
just gonna get the wall
get the side wall go to the town one
night
that is um i say nice
i don't know what he hit but it was nice
and what the hell hi okay it must be the
boots man
you hit the tentacle let's just say that
they hit a hidden tentacle in it
the invisible tentacles
what a conversion there from complaints
oh boy oh boy oh that's gonna be it nice
complain with the first match and
there's gonna be there's gonna need to
be some serious adaptation done here
from luffy because i mean even though he
got around complaining looked
comfortable and that those combos the
oaky everything one point yeah even that
conversion when it was like weird it
looked like he kind of went to the side
and behind him and he still managed to
get the combo off of that and maximum
conversion that's that's how you know
he's a character specialist when you're
converting stuff like that where you're
you're on the right side and you go to
the left side behind him on the wall
splat and you're still getting off the
wall to get a tailspin
man
you are you're a character specialist at
that point for sure and and there's a
lot of things that i know complain
hasn't even done yet like he has a lot
more tricks um up them sleeves you know
because i've played him i've seen him
play as well a lot and i just know for a
fact with all the stuff that yoshi did
there's a few things that yoshi got in
this new season that that if he gets put
onto the back foot there's things he can
bring out we haven't even seen him use
the flash yet you know what i mean
complain is in a great position because
his first or two and he hasn't even used
a fraction of what he's capable of doing
with yoshi so now i think luffy has to
do a lot of adaptation work here yes
definitely a lot of adaptation well he
was promising he seemed like the he lost
the first round he was in control of
that with a back one two like he said
but probably testing on the waters
probably shouldn't have done that
probably just you know committed to a
back one see if he reacts like a twitch
doc and then you know okay this guy's on
point you know he's he's looking for
that he's ready he's seen it he kind of
just put it out as a commitment
unfortunately there was docked and lost
the round that could have been two
rounds a piece and they could be
fighting for the final round i don't
think it was
too far gone from luffy you can
definitely make the comebacks what i'm
trying to say yeah yeah okay winners
semi-finals here one oh jungle outpost
uh again it's gonna it's a good stage to
go to because of course with paul having
the breakable balcony and the breakable
wall um it allows him to get some pretty
serious damage if you can get get there
but let's see man serious adaptation
needs to be done here from luffy hey
okay he went for that unconventional
punishment on the low there just you
know caught him in the headlights he's
watching
yeah
he uses that power crush how far are we
going okay
yeah
oh a nice bit but doesn't really
capitalize off of it
okay a little bit of that spacing game
now okay gets the punish
he's fishing for that downpour too
that's one of the additions that most
you got in this game i remember i think
older tekken iterations that down before
two did not launch like that
yeah nice oh boy
please
yeah you've got to be very careful there
when yoshi has raised because his rage
drive is like 40 i think 14 frames so
it's very quick and it high crushes too
so you know good stuff then luffy with
the patience yeah just wait um um
complain just to basically kill himself
you know you actually can do that as
well but you know in an unconventional
way he killed himself
to make sure he's not stepping out the
wall just oh that was sick ninja's out
of there okay no slow start you haven't
seen that's the first time i went for a
flash there
yeah
luffy was probably not
probably wasn't expecting it he was
backing out
i'm loving this from luffy a lot more
patience now bubs you can see right yeah
well i guess now he has to be he
complained showing him the flash so i
guess you have to oh
as i said before the match that crash
that's three plus four what are you
doing luffy oh my god this guy's trying
to start on him he's like now i'm going
to go for the big what instant 193. he
doesn't have to do it but he's trying to
do it anyway two rounds up now
adaptation is being made and then again
you saw it there going for the crash
three plus four he's going for the flash
punish now the thing is it's very it's
inconsistent you saw it hit last round
but that time it didn't it really
depends on like the angle and the
distance he does it from the wall
there's a lot of to go into that
yeah for sure nice side step down for
two it's going to get blocked complain
now putting on some pressure nice gets
the flip over oh we
yeah that should reach the wall yeah
that's going to be nice nice complaint
on the board this is good
you know sometimes people forget man
don't take real versus yoshi man in
certain situations
but it's even hard because now he's got
that uh is it crash that's one that hits
grounded so it's like a mix-up game in
itself oh that was unfortunate i thought
he had the correct read there but you
know he read the wrong book like what
was that he read the wrong book he had
to crack right read but you know he read
the wrong book for his homework you know
but he did read it let's just say that
that is he gonna get the yo yo yo
that was a conversion and a half a down
four or two raw
yeah i love it he caught himself step
into buttons
and he's gonna go to the wall okay no
okay it has no oh just sweeps him again
he's gonna get a full conversion out of
that complaint working his way back two
rounds a piece
yeah we're on set point now for
complaining to move into winners finals
here guys and put luffy into the loser
bracket can luffy bring it back okay
that hit kind of weird there nice nice
making the reading he knows that when
complaining blocks the lows he wants to
go for that sword sweep
that was sick yeah let's put the throw
break oh you need to be very careful
showing that complaint complaining
showing that he's trying to use that
flash for a pressure alleviation
careful careful careful not punish
did he try to crack cancel um defense
there i don't know
oh god punish complain now go to the
sword sweep be careful all keys this is
scary flip over and attack rolls
complain he's going to take your 2-0
with a lovely comeback in the final
round 2-0 over luffy that was a that was
a bit of a heartbreaker i want to go
back because he blocked the low
and then it looked like i don't know if
he blocked it by accident maybe back
dash and just wasn't ready and then yeah
okay let me just quickly try this death
fist
but that that could have been the round
it could have been one one that was it
was very unfortunate i want to say that
yeah i think he wanted to go for the um
the launch but one of those situations
sometimes you accidentally block lows
right when you're back dashing uh you
might hit that down back input and then
you end up knocking and it blocks the
low you weren't ready for it but as you
can see there the lone israeli in this
top eight will move into winners finals
and our next match coming up is going to
be devil rocky versus ultra instinct
potato double rocking saudi arabia
audrey insane potato from georgia and i
believe bubsy this might be a king
mirror match
you like king right
he's a clean character i used to play
king way back actually
no i think it's like it was just the
other day but i'm like nah nah it was
actually kind of way back when i used to
play games
long time yeah i mean uh the thing is
that i feel like double rocky plays a
lot of different characters devil uh
uh ultra into potato hasn't really i
haven't seen him play a lot
i've played his king and i can tell you
that it is very very very fundamentally
the punishment he rarely misses the the
throw mix-ups he's very good at doing
the mixing mixing it up with the mids
all the time he's a very strong
king player but again
uh like i said in saudi arabia how many
king players you guys have devil rocky's
one of them federer of course one of the
best king players in the world we have
uh kyle if you guys remember kaya if you
any of you guys from pre-tech and seven
some of you guys who under 17 as you
know if you know kaya uh back when he
lived in california and he he did great
he won tournaments he got me
top eight i want to say do you not black
break really high in evo once please i
think he did get evo top eight one time
two yeah so
like there is there there are a lot of
good
solid kings in saudi arabia i feel like
if you want to be one of the best guys
in
in saudi arabia you have to be prepared
for king because you know you're gonna
come come across one of these guys right
especially with federer doing how well
he's been doing recently so yeah let's
see but again it's sometimes about
styles as well because king can be
played in a variety of ways some people
use certain maybe more throw-based
something more poke-based uh using the
sharp more downfall two staying in your
face everyone plays a bit differently
right ultra potato and devil rocky maybe
he won't be ready for the georgian style
of king yeah it would be very
interesting like he said um all trains
taylor was an icfc winner so he's he's
got that tournament credential
is it going to be the mirror i wonder
it is oh [ __ ] here we go both what tgo
both tgo as well
look at the winds from ultra into potato
in player match
that's five
almost six thousand that's what i've
ever done in my lifetime on on ranked
offline online
holy cow all right ladies and gents here
we go put your bets in in the chat here
for the channel points who do you think
is going to take it saudi arabia
versus georgia devil rocky versus ultra
instinct potato a king mirror match
we'll get some wrestling here ladies and
gents before who is going to meet
complain in that winner's finals
let's go it's going gonna be very
interesting to see they're both looking
the man in the mirror at a minute they
see each other you know that spider-man
meme is pointing at each other
all right here we go
devil rocking with that ten win streak
okay bear can't hit back one to get
things started
yeah okay running power bomb nice pushes
him towards the wall
nice block on the low
oh
giant swing oh let's go that was it that
is so tight
oh oh my gosh flip was that i nearly
threw up
what was that
i wonder if that's the actual set up
there because that was clean
yeah oh nice he actually did something
there not the best combo nice oaky
that's that was guaranteed that low kick
and goes for the ford freak d d t
nice i actually done a little bit of
research about ddt you know and where
that move actually came from the name
actual real wrestling i tell them
i want to know now is something like to
do in an insecticide like jake the snake
or something
and it kills them yeah it's something
like that weird like that
nice
okay
it was a good start there for double
rocky to start off that first round but
ultron to potato he managed to bring it
back the throw breaks are on point now
as well okay he ain't breaking giant
swings yeah
well like he said jack with king is a
mix up on the frozen it actually does
sometimes look like a one plus two throw
so it's hard you can't break the movie
king that's that's the thing is this
sometimes it's just nice
this is crazy right now man with how
many saudi arabians were having this top
eight is it gonna be a non-saudi in that
uh in that winner's finals why it may
have a saudi goo like in a minute that's
everyone in the loser
this is such a good performance here
from ultron so like i said he picks his
shot so wisely yeah he's so fundamental
he knows when to throw and he knows when
to go for the post and here we go nice
break
and guess whoa there you go side step
two this is gonna be it keeps the combo
nice and simple three rounds straight
there
damn ultra instinct potato man
yeah i mean this is what we're used to
seeing this is actually what we're used
to seeing from ultramarine potato when
he when he's on point he sometimes is
unstoppable like you know i mean it's
something sometimes could just be
unstoppable i feel like he's in the he's
in the mode uh if you're playing against
king again breaking giant swings man
it's not the best situation for you i
want to know what happened with that
forward one plus four it looked like it
crossed behind him and
i i really wonder if that was some some
technology i know i i definitely believe
that was some georgian technology uh
from altering the potato and it looked
like the the back 10 4 was was
guaranteed yeah that was definitely that
king didn't know what was going on like
he yeah he has no clue i had no clue he
was like how do i block this is it can i
block can i know yeah but i wonder
what's he gonna go for now does he go to
the um you can't even really comfortably
go to forgotten rome because even though
you have the uh that's
i mean your opponent has the same
advantage as well right so what do you
do here that is a very big risk to go
for the forgotten realm now you got to
be confident in yourself there that
you know that you're gonna get to that
we're we've already seen a world record
um for the forgotten realm like getting
to the bottom floor
he needs to run that world record that
speed run on that if you're going to use
it
okay no keeps it mission madojo okay
i'll respect it
yeah look like he chose the stage as
well right yeah he did yeah okay
interesting
just probably waiting some down time
just to kind of think about what you
what you could do what you and what
changes he needs to make
um okay it'll be interesting to see
all right let's go man second game
incoming ultimate has all of the
momentum nice so he's he's already
looking like he's using those jabs just
to kind of stop um straight into potato
getting something started
oh man oh yo bob's yeah breaking throws
man well he's mixing are you coming
playing against a king player like
alternatively and not be breaking throws
it's hard to be he's mixing them up
really well he's that's the first time
i've seen the two throw
okay guess i can't hit they've got
people's elbows
out there
go to the shop that would that was very
unfortunate it looked like it would have
punished but i guess kings
on that
yeah
nice oh harry is he gonna get something
can he kill though the wall's there
no oh oh oh kill
what's
now
on oh my god
we need to re-run on that one that was
insane
left right and center can you see the
var on that one
i need to see it
damn that was so unfortunate for devil
rocky there
yeah i really feel like he needed that
round two bubsy because of the last
match was so dominant for ultra patel
and double rocky he's not looking so
good now
yeah i hope that doesn't dishearten him
it's definitely going to man okay just
evading everything in a minute
okay back one time can't hit cut a duck
there
nice block oh that was the right punch
but he didn't get it though just a
little bit too slowly it looked like he
did hesitate a little bit on the punish
yeah
oh he's really he wants that backbone
punished but he's not just a little bit
late on it yeah oh no what are we going
to go for now oh are we going to see it
are we going to see it no we didn't
uh-uh it's still going to kill
the damage all right ladies and lads
ultra in sick potato from georgia on set
points and move to winners finals
against complain looking very impressive
okay are we going to see a rolling death
cradle nope just gonna go for the
russian deck sweep
instead now an armbar
oh yeah what's the okay okay nice in the
back
okay now this is what i want to see just
use your that's it use that momentum
okay using those jabs
nice can't hit there
don't tell me he's going to make a
comeback here ultra is the potato taking
it to the wall now rage available needs
to be very careful nice with punished on
the down back too
yeah
all right he's still awake he's not
sleeping just yet
yeah but he's gonna need a reverse
repair man i'm telling you all
he knows when to pick his shots he knows
when to go for the throws and he's
mixing it up here now bubsy
did he just he's giving him about the
same mommy product he just ate
he just done the same change this isn't
messy
and the punishment looked quite there as
well good shining was in no break yeah
that was his oh just giant sings him out
of his throat attempting to look like it
looked like he was going for a crash
mixed up throw doesn't tech that is huge
damages ian does have rage available can
make a comeback
okay try to go for that shotgun account
here and gets easter jabs this is last
chance saloon here and goes to the
upward three
taking it yeah
that is gonna be it ultra into potato
gonna take it over double rocky two oh
man it just looked like devil rocky was
so uncomfortable the way that the way
that um the alternative was playing i'm
going to call him potato so
potato was playing he was in his face
just poking making the right decisions
over and over again and that means later
that it's going to be complain versus uh
potato for our winners finals and no no
saudi arabian in the winner's side right
now and they've all been pushed to
losers but yeah let's see if they can
make a comeback in the loser's side man
oh yeah i'm gonna have some replays here
as well
yeah this was an interesting match
because i feel like luffy was
he made he was making the comeback in
the second game right but he didn't
block what the the very clutch low and
just allow the complaint to get the
momentum yeah let's see they're taking
into that unblockable i think this is
what that was seen
he went for the low there i think it's
the one that the end that goes out for
free that takes it nice and simple that
moves so good that that is like the king
randomly you see that brian's did a
backpack um before he just flips over
and just chuckles the whole screen for
some odd reason from a backpack but
i don't know yeah that's just the king
ender right there
yeah so solid solid stuff there from uh
potato he moves in i feel like double
rocky just wasn't comfortable and he was
panicking quite a bit committing to
things that he shouldn't have really
committed to even at the end there when
the while 74 um
he kind of in those crumble situations
ultra inseparated was so much better uh
so yeah that means that we are going to
be moving into our loser's bracket
ladies and gents but once again check it
out guys this is a schedule for our
master events just look at all the
regions that are represented here and
it's so amazing and bubbly just like you
said it's a true rock it's a true role
tour definitely it's it's global man
this is the globe
no yeah yeah it's not just it's not just
asia europe and america like it's been
like east asia like this is actually
literally like we know second players
are all around the world man and this is
what we want to do i know that it's it's
online it's not a it's not perfect like
you it's not offline right but at the
end of the day
what this has allowed us to have is is
people who can't travel offline who are
very solid very strong have even been
able to get sponsors because of their
performances online right young players
that haven't been able to travel so this
has been good in its own way and i feel
like there's um
going to be a lot more players that we
learn about in the in the upcoming weeks
as well so this is the schedule for it
guys the online masters and the regional
so definitely put that on your calendar
man definitely mark it down i got my
calendar i always keep everything in my
phone these days and just make sure to
register we kind of stress this enough
make sure to register yourself to be
part of the leaderboard you don't want
to have your points not talk time you
don't want to have that huge win that
confidence booster and then you don't
get a point so make sure you register
you know because submissions do end on
the first of october and that is the
stone's throw away it's not that long so
make sure you do submit
yeah absolutely man the online dodgers
as well uh if you are a to and you're
interested to have your tournament be
part of the second online challenge 2021
then make sure that you get your
application in before that before
october 10th because the submissions uh
will be uh will end at that point and
you will not be allowed to be part of
the tour so make sure you have them
because they if you are a to uh it is
very important to have these online
dojos for your regions because it could
allow your uh your players to make it
into that top that top position on the
tlc especially in the middle east
because you know right now there are not
many people that have that many points
so uh yeah definitely get your
submissions before october 10th and
right now guys we're going into the
loser side we're gonna have a saudi
versus saudi and then jordan versus
saudi sorry versus bk that would be jin
versus gigas and then mohammed misha
[ __ ]
versus link
yeah is it one thing i've noticed
actually we've had a good character like
diversity already right we've seen apart
from the king mirror match but
it's been a good um diverse class of
characters and that's that's just a
compliment to the game second seven in
the state that it is at a minute because
it just shows that
you can pick any character and and it's
more or less going to make it work we
saw a noctis win like how long was it
two weeks ago
yeah yeah ducky man
yeah yeah definitely man that's that's
what it is man like i feel uh you can
win with any character in character
really any character like you you saw a
ranch you do with the panda we saw uh
ducky do with the noctis i'm not saying
obviously about character i think it's
good but like gigas as well we've seen
people winning icfcs left right and
center with gigas so i really feel like
you have the passion you like your
character enough and you're i've got
character loyalists as well getting
rewarded a lot in this game because it's
just that kind of that kind of game
right so i'm looking forward to seeing
this match it's going to be gin versus
gig ass
not a match up you see that often hey
bob z no but let's go definitely and get
one of those characters i i i i like a
gigas
i
yes yeah all right all right all right
and we know that bk has a we saw his
first match to qualify for top eight he
was very wild i played him myself as
well he's very good at using moves that
you don't usually see with um we get gas
as well so let's get into it i never
knew that gigas had a hot kick i never
knew he could do that
and i wonder how much these guys have
played against each other as well you
know because they've also said you're
about to play in tournaments yeah it's
true there could be a bit of mind games
going on here okay this is guaranteed
yep that is guaranteed on big bodies i
never knew that was has that always been
a thing from season yeah i think it has
been yeah um that the cancun's in that
situation it kills the bears i think
jack and jason yeah
yeah
all right nice first round there's solid
first round from wraith
and you know what's crazy bob see that
first dan is much more uh i feel like
terrifying than the omega i know why
it's just so much scarier it's just like
it lures you into a full sense of
security
i'm scared i don't know what's going on
i don't know what to expect here man
all right nice
go to the five star frog splash
you can actually see how long his arms
are
yeah the strings just that keypad game
using those jabs you're not down forward
one
yeah
i feel like that was going to be a big
factor in this matchup that parry versus
uh gigas especially with bk using that
headbutt a lot unfortunate there gets a
10 frame punish
okay just backing up
i don't want to commit to anything just
now oh
yeah let's talk about it doesn't want to
commit too much but guess count here
i like that yeah just be very careful
hey back he's against the wall race does
have rage
oh
okay down two can't get a conversion
that can't hit
unless he's
[Music]
just called him out these guys have
definitely played before man rife knew
exactly what bk was gonna do there and
he actually matched after the rage drive
so it was a call out rave actually
jumped before the race drive actually
came out because he thought he had to
read their nice parry yeah
i got the combo right here i'm gonna
dial it in right now
yeah beautiful yeah it's so good there
from rafe and multiple scenarios yeah he
knew that that uh bk he did that in the
first match actually remember he did the
rage driving he actually waited um he
knew he's gonna do that punished him
with the 2-4 using the parry beautifully
not spamming it not using it too much
but in certain scenarios where he knows
his timing he uses a parry and gets a
full launch the combos as well with the
kancans everything's on point here yes
definitely and let's i just want to
reiterate the point that when jin uses
his parry it's not a guaranteed like
punish on like a shredder it's like he
has to know it looks like he's done the
like the research because he knows
exactly okay this is
this this is guaranteed to shred is
guaranteed sometimes you may do a move
and it's not guaranteed because it
recovers a lot quicker so it looks like
definitely he's done his homework here
probably definitely played together i
think because from when he jumped back
for the race drive like before and then
um bk kind of delayed his race drive and
done it after he landed
right like that shows that these two
have played each other before i i'll i'm
a better man i'm gonna put mine yeah
yeah for sure i mean and even if they
haven't like you can just see like the
the match-up knowledge that he has for
uh for 4k assets too is good but bk is a
very experienced player himself i know
that there were you could see that in
that match there was a potential
potential for him to get good punishment
yeah uh you could see that he was trying
to condition him with the down forward
four so gigas is down forward four one
plus two it's a kick into headbutt right
yeah and uh it's got like an 11 frame
gap so you can you can you can go for a
jab or or something to interrupt it and
he was trying to bait that out of race
but rife wasn't wasn't going for it um
so like bk i think there is some
information that he's gathered here and
let's see if he's able to apply it and
he's gonna go to the forgotten realm as
well party stage to try to get that
maximum damage here bubsy maximum damage
let's see if he's gonna try to do that
speed run right yeah would you say 18.67
seconds yeah 18.67 seconds guys is the
world record for breaking all of the
floors
and there's already three seconds past
it's not looking good it's not looking
good at the speed running okay here we
go you're getting downstairs oh it
doesn't get the jab oh
yeah that was an unfortunate drop there
gonna get to the wall yeah going
downstairs definitely now
all right
oh i thought we're gonna get a combo
video right there
and again all right just you know
oh nice good counter hit down four two
okay nice option not break the floor
and
characters are so really strong
oh johanna here we go
okay big car hit flips him it doesn't
get the score i don't get it that's
unfortunate there down to
okay
oh boy oh no this is this is sometimes
well it happens sometimes it is online
you know it happens it's it's not it
does happen all the way does happen yeah
you know when like
lemon
lemonade
however right this might actually work
out in favor of uh of of bk a little bit
because the momentum was there man
momentum was was really really uh in his
favor yeah with drive so who knows
what's gonna happen here bk he's got a
thank allah for that man
he wasn't looking very good there man he
was all over him so let's see what
happens once we get we're going to get
back in later we will hopefully get back
on the same stage break the floor
whatever and reset uh with that but yeah
uh rife was all over in bubsy yeah
like like you said it's a blessing in
this in disguise and it gets a little
time to just cool down just
think like what happened what can i do
differently you know
yeah
but i i would say try and like it seems
like once raf gets going it's it's i
guess gigas so he needs to use the long
to lock the long reach of gas to try and
keep him out it seems like once he gets
that wave dash going and gets in his
face and puts him in that mix up you
know gin has a strong health sleep he
has a strong mid game and accident you
can launch him also has an electric so
you can pressure him he just kind of
needs to
mitigate and stop that and i guess gigas
as well being a big character so it's
harder for him to step out of these
things
so once you have those kind of
characters you kind of need to think
okay so i can't step i need another
option to stop people just mauling me
down and that's when the long um limbs
come into play
yeah it's those arms right i think the
jab needs to be used a bit better here
from from bk um because right now rife
rife is getting in very easily is
allowing him to get in and pressure him
this matchup doesn't seem to be too good
for gigas to be honest but you have to
work around it by using the jab i think
that using the jab might be because i
don't know if jin has that many uh high
crush tools apart from down four which
is a very consistent high crush i mean
how many high crushing tools does he
have i think the electric sometimes
might be able to go underneath the jab
in some scenarios but you know generally
speaking using the jab might be a very
good way to for him to just keep him out
keep him humble and at that time slow
down the match once the match is slowed
down then you guys can actually maybe
maybe get something started because
something started i want to think maybe
also um
gigas has that forward one plus two just
that head box sometimes there's a check
just oh yeah yeah yeah yeah just to you
know sometimes you have to be a little
bit disrespectful you know like we saw
it like way earlier on in the tournament
where um the i can't remember the link
player when he's using the standing four
against dragon off like just when
off the back one plus two like sometimes
you need to just
put a reality check and just see it out
there i think gigas's forward one plus
two is a good answer because once you
get that on car here it gives you that
position it pushes them towards the wall
and then you know it's a scary move
that's huge damage as well so maybe
utilize that a little bit more obviously
it's the highest it can be ducks you
need to be careful and use it sparingly
and accordingly like probably don't
don't use it too obviously because
i'm sure
um
it'll catch on to it for sure but uh the
players are coming back in now ladies
and gents uh once again thank you for
your patience thanks for waiting we all
want to see some second action you know
and we're gonna get back into it very
shortly once again you know uh tekken
online challenge middle east if you're
just tuning in uh we're very happy to be
bringing you this because me and bubsy
were at the we were commenting the uh
the finals for the the middle east the
first master event in dubai yeah that
happened in 2019 rocks and roll dubai
man it was a great experience for us to
go down there meet a lot of the middle
east players for the first time and man
i just i'm so sad that we weren't able
to do it in 2020 it's going to be in in
jordan yeah for the marshall event for
the fate of the fate tournament but man
hopefully soon man hopefully soon next
year you know like
hopefully next year we'll see that stuff
right so we're going back in and we're
probably going to break one of the
floors as well because i feel like we
broke one of the floors uh they might
not even give a damn they're just going
to reset the round maybe but either way
we're coming back in here we go
rife did have the first round
yeah okay so yeah
i guess we're not probably going to
break the floor but yeah
nice nice nice nice you put the ball
yeah these guys know man i don't know
what i'm saying you know
sportsmanship so we're gonna get
straight back into it right now
bars and meters that we have to worry
about you know oh yeah none of that [ __ ]
man
all right it's nice let's go
join them again we're going downstairs
yeah
okay looks like him before election it
doesn't duck the second hit of two four
big boo
nice conversion there
oh wait wait
okay this time gets a flip over
guaranteed
yeah no dark ah he's not ducking that
yeah
you should try to fish for a counter hit
jab again four two once again it big
with no power no launch yeah that was a
big opportunity there could have got the
launch
put race in a bad position
hopefully doesn't come back to haunt him
that's why i talked about using that jab
he's not been using it too much he's
letting him get in and that's down two
gonna kill right now on one round away
from moving on in this topic loses
exactly what we said before he needs to
try and keep him out this is that once
he gets in it's impossible to get him
out
you know it's like blue tech in here
final destination what's the combo eight
eight okay nice
nice blocking the down too but just get
two full gets gonna get the reward splat
but
messed up on the combo a little bit yeah
oh he's doubting himself now bubsy he
doesn't know what to do his mind is
boggled and that is gonna be it right if
with three rounds straight i'm gonna
eliminate bk from the tournament bk
though a top eight finish for him gotta
be proud with that but all right if
we'll move on yeah it just seemed like
that um that gin pressure was just one
a little bit too much there it's quite
unfortunate um obviously they had a
little bit of downtime could affected
him a little bit but
you know i guess going forward like you
know is it it's going to be joint
seventh right i'm not good at these
numbers so yeah yeah that's that's
that's seventh for life and uh our next
match is going to be as you can see
in the bracket mohammed mishima from
jordan going up against masood and you
know these jordanians when i was in
jordan they were telling me about their
community in amman right um being the
main city of jordan and they were saying
that we have about 20 players that come
offline and we play uh you know that's
the that's the size of their community
and we saw and i want to reiterate this
is a story that i've talked quite a few
times but they had a kid who was six
years old oh yeah you know holding his
little uh ps4 pad and he played versus
knee with kazuya and hit me with three
electrics into back two one like
consistently and me was like what the
hell like this kid he's a kid and he's
doing these mad combos and um
you know they're telling me how
passionate their scene is and man
there's so many um players from that one
of them actually bi musician and did
really well with the other koreans in
tournaments so
man these these guys are these guys are
pretty good man and we're going to see
one of them coming up now um in the
loser bracket this is all about leveling
up them scenes and i like the sound of
actually a nice tight knit community
it's just you know everyone learns off
each other and it's it's beautiful to
see like i said you know they've already
got their young generation coming up he
says how was he six years old dude in
the election he was like six years old i
think yeah i couldn't do an election
until i was i was in double digits mate
ahead of the game i was in way double
digits i remember and if you if you
don't believe me you go ask me because
it wasn't on stream it was casuals
before the tournament uh on day one so i
was watching and i promise you that's
what happened and you can ask me if you
don't believe me yeah that he played
against his kid and the kid was very
strong movement the wave dash is on
point with the with the pad and i'm like
damn this kid is gonna be super good you
know like he's already good but he's
gonna like that's what i mean about
these these communities sometimes these
communities are very small no one really
thinks about them but what i love to see
is having tournaments like this the
second online challenge for the master
event and then even bringing offline uh
to the middle east you know which is
something that hasn't really happened
before for uh fgc games you know but
second you know they took the initiative
they moved into the middle east and they
said let's have a master event there and
they did it and and look what we were
able to see a lot of talented players
come out come out the woodworks
definitely wonderful i can't believe it
was um that long ago like to be hit the
time warp you know two years later it's
crazy it was two years but the
community's actually grown quite a bit
but that's the thing you know from 2019
when we were flying around the world
commenting tech and world tours together
and it's like now there's a lot of
players that have come come out from
like um
from online you know uh players in
europe in america in in i guess even in
the middle east and asia too like
players that we didn't know much about
before and it's it's brought something
different i think and you know i i'm
just i just can't wait to see these
players come and do their thing you know
it'll be very interesting so we're going
to get into our next match now which is
going to be
mohammed masood
and he's almost dude going for the cuny
mitsu versus the link now i
think that this could be a
a good choice actually i think that cuny
has some tools to
to to maybe
beat some of the stuff that that link
can throw out with her stances but also
finally people are realizing how strong
cuny mysteries i've been saying it for a
long time and people are like no she's
not that good her nose are kind of whack
she is very strong people even rating
her like we've seen the tearless come
out from the koreans rating her higher
than zafina and other characters so like
she's very strong let's see what music
man well yeah she's definitely i i i
like i know about the 2-2 stuff
for the wrong reasons
getting hit by everything nice
a great punish they threaded that one
yeah
he's backing up together okay nice that
now that kunai is um i think that move
is very good honestly yeah it's like a
full screen instant
uh move basically yeah yeah in certain
scenarios let's say for example if
you're playing versus like a an akuma or
a geese or something and they throw out
fireballs the the kunai is so quick and
it's like you said it covers pretty much
full screen um you'll be able to punish
it so in certain scenarios it's a good
move to throw and it can catch out your
movement very easily at max range or
even at far range uh it doesn't she
doesn't come in enough for you to punish
yeah so it's actually safe for certain
ranges yeah definitely i know way too
much about that move before then
i don't know did you get the cuny mr
treatment yeah
please i've got the i got the queen
mitchu treatment with the adnan laughs
oh boy all right here we go
shout out okay you
cancel that goes for me trying to mix up
a little bit oh as we say about the the
kunai oh that was a big opportunity for
whiff punished there
okay very patient in a minute
okay can you use that
oh
big launch and this could potentially be
the round against the right combo okay
a little bit um didn't calculate the
wall flat properly
oh boy oh boy
nice nice good stuff masood guess the
round
lovely
i wonder why he chose cooney
all right now okay that wasn't a punish
but good stuff anyway um
or was it because it's a knee i don't
know yeah i might say that i think those
ones are weird it's a bit of a weird one
okay gets a flip over here what's the
mix up
about to get the world to be very
careful
he gets the walls
caught them airborne
oh my god i don't even know what that
move was
i'm okay yeah you went for the stance
okay for no no punish on the hot knees
unfortunately
goes for the mid option back turn
forward one plus two masseuse now one
round away from taking the first match
okay just backing up
just he's just whipping the down is that
down four twos right
yeah
he wants him to run into it
good ten frame punish back ten throw
that's not mix up
okay
yeah okay again visitor yes the throw
yeah see that's what makes it it wasn't
second take two like
link had a legit back 10 throw mixer but
she doesn't have it anymore yeah nice yo
some of your own medicine you're not
gonna kill though
oh
but is it he is in a great position but
needs to be very careful with the rage
drive but
yeah no just happens just keeps it nice
and simple with the down four
yeah from crouch down four
good launch lovely lovely good drop in
the combo
it's getting a little bit scrappy now
all right show me some sidestep threes
nice punish
can i get to the walls gonna keep it
nice and simple no drops the combo
it's really unfortunate here oh that's
-14 good punish
okay
bruh
okay okay
nice good punish
nice great i'm just wow turn four
is that guaranteed that that kind of
maybe could be guaranteed because she
was back tonight as well yeah no she's
better so in that situation um
they nerfed it as well so when you do
that one throw and it broke i think you
were neutral it was both guys were
neutral in that situation now i think
you're minus but that that back ten
launcher was not guaranteed you could
you definitely could have turned around
yeah um
and even has moves of her own from back
turn cuny mitsu has her own kind of uh
you know a back turn that she does um
and she could have probably counter hit
that but that was a great read uh but
yeah i would like i would like to see
some side step threes from ling in that
much what do you think bubsy you know
the sweet the launcher
iii yeah what do you think um
it is um
kind of
seeable again
is it though is it is it really though i
don't know this five bar connection do
you think so what do you guys think at
home do you guys think we should see
some links sidestep threes i would i
would personally love to see yourself
but it is what it is that the ghetto
mixed up so i said three cancel it into
back turn back down four yeah the
classic classic you want to see those
you're bringing it to the streets now
yeah look them online street mix-ups
yeah that
are
bringing it into the superman the market
you get me
they can bring it to the superman but
yeah um
let's get into our next match
and is he gonna switch characters is he
gonna go to
[Music]
this is a match that i am very
unfamiliar with
it's a matchup that used to be okay for
gigas i feel like um hey we know jamie
from ireland right now for fallout and
he he was um very strong versus ling he
used to do um he had options you know
down back to and downfall one these kind
of things could really shut down ling
but i feel like ling has just been
buffed quite a bit and and has the tools
needed to beat gigas now you know yeah
um so let's see what happens here gigas
from masoud
thank you it'll be interesting there's
one match that i'm not really familiar
with so it'll be interesting for me to
learn i always like learning
yeah and of course that down to is minus
14 so the standing three from um from
ling will launch it
[Music]
oh boy nice
too okay now he's just applying that
pressure using those plus frames
not letting him get anything started
oh no okay nice hops out
rage drive
this is just not going to be the round
sorry yeah i lied to everyone
that unscaled damage at the end with the
spike into back turn for mohammed mishma
from jordan representing here
nice
oh
okay on points oh the candy roll
this is not looking good from a suit at
all okay no that doesn't work and get
just got pigeon legs
oh boy yeah okay here we go
gonna get a full conversion rate this
does have the ratios of additional
damage okay is that gonna hit it right
yeah
it did it no it didn't it didn't take
roll
that wasn't again that wasn't guaranteed
there was no tech roll no
combo man
oh [ __ ] that you're trying to go for a
10x combo you cheeky cheeky devil
yeah
he's pulling out all the stops there man
he's pulling out all the stops
okay now gets across up there
here just using all right using that
movement trying to get no
oh my god but you know in the moment
i think he's going through the gigas the
move list he must have it like on his
side he's like okay what's the next move
all right yeah down back to down four
three okay what's the next one
nice
nice low parry
okay
yeah right a very entertaining set there
very eventful
first or two with uh masood and um
muhammad mishima but masood gonna finish
with seventh place not a bad showing at
all for him
but he's out the tournament now and uh
yeah we're gonna see we're gonna still
be seeing some jordanian tekken action
here in this uh bracket yes so that's
kind of like the first that's the first
wave done right
yeah like from the loser bracket yes
round one done um
maybe we can have a look at the brackets
and here it is yes so
um we're going to be getting
mohammed mishima versus md luffy um for
that matching losers devil rocky versus
rife as well so that would be a king
versus jin and with the way that life
has been playing man it's he's been
looking very solid and that match with
bk definitely has given him some
momentum and of course sitting in the
winner's side still we have israel
versus georgia potato versus complaining
so uh a lot of diversity still here
bubsy
a lot to look forward to
yes we don't have a lot to look forward
to i'm interested i'm going to see i'm
interested in these matches like me
coming up it's going to be
good ass tekken and speaking of
good ass tekken
um
[Music]
let's get these sick t-shirts i've said
this before that bait that blue one
stamp of approval i need i need that for
myself but yeah you can scan the qr code
it takes you straight to the merch store
make sure you get your merch because
these are selling out like hot cakes you
know they're flying off the shelves man
yeah definitely man and uh you know a
lot of them are already sold out these
are just the ones that they've restocked
and they're only back for a limited time
as well so we've got the bruce lee
colors any of you guys are big fans of
bruce lee the law uh make sure you get
your hands on these because these are
officially licensed you know a lot of
people have been asking for more merch
when you're taking uh from the tekken
side of things you know other games have
a lot of it and now finally you know
tekken has been getting a lot of these
um you know officially licensed tekken
merchandise man so definitely get a hand
on those tenno dot gg4 slash merch
before they sell out nice shout out to
10 0 man
uh of course guys make sure to follow as
well uh to keep up to date with
everything be any esports uh for twitter
and youtube and of course tekken for
twitter twitch and facebook if you want
to keep up to date with all what's going
on in the tekken world
yes exactly so right now we are gonna go
for another short break so make sure you
go get your refreshments because when we
come back we've been down to the final
six right yep six guys left we're gonna
get straight back into this good ass
tekken you know we're gonna come back to
the losers quarter so stay tuned don't
go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
not
she's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
done
[Music]
do
[Music]
rose
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys welcome back to the toc
tekken online challenge for the middle
east i hope you guys are refreshed use
that break to you know get your drinks
ready because we are going to get
straight into this
good tekken so i'm obviously joined by
my partner spang which side is it that
side outside yeah yeah
what's up man are you guys doing yes top
six action here for the tlc middle east
uh it's been good like we said we still
have a lot of diversity here we have
four different uh countries represented
israel georgia saudi arabia and uh
jordan so uh yeah i'm excited for this
in our top six i we love to see uh
diversity that's what we love to see
right we thought coming into today that
saudi arabia would be probably the most
the more uh dominant people but looking
at who we have in the winners winners of
finals like it's it's very um like it's
very interesting that we have israel and
uh
and georgia but once again ladies and
gents uh a big shout out to astro our
official headset makes up for the tekken
online challenge 2021
but yes um like i was saying the winners
uh finals is is not is there's no saudis
man like and that was a surprise to me
but looking at who we have there with
complaining and patel uh it's like you
know not that much i wouldn't say it was
an upset no definitely not upset these
those complain and ultra instant potato
guys yeah you said i'm gonna call him ui
potato
it's a mouthful it's still early over
here but you know those two
i think they played outstanding matches
so yeah they deserve to be in the
winner's final it's going to be an
interesting minister when you get there
but we are going to go into the losers
court final i'm just going to go into
the gulag for a bit you know
yeah absolutely
thank you like first off we have devil
rocky from saudi arabia going up against
from saudi arabia as well king versus
jhin most likely for that one and then
of course md luffy versus muhammad
mishima from jordan saudi versus jordan
for the paul versus link matchup most
likely i don't think we're going to see
too much devil rocky though does play a
variety of characters i've seen him play
a variety of characters in tournament as
well so i wonder if uh devil rocky will
will maybe switch up the uh
the characters here maybe he's playing
against before this with his uh king and
wasn't able to win who knows there's
definitely some prior knowledge that's
going to be going into this match right
unless it's going to be very
that's when tekken gets um
that's when the heat and the level and
the excitement like all levels up a
little bit more when people are familiar
with each other and they're able to play
that extra mental mind game and that's
when the little interest intricacies
that you'll see like we saw it before um
with mrf versus mbk when he done the
jump back but he delayed his rage drive
to kind of catch him on when he fall
back down and jump back so it's these
little intricacies that actually it
takes the game to a you know it's like
when you get some something nice you add
a little bit of seasoning on it you know
it's
just
yeah it's a little bit better
yeah so what do you expect for this one
man right has a lot of momentum going in
from that match that he had with bk it's
going to be the gin versus the king i
mean
who do you expect to win this one oh
that's going to be
primarily i would say as if you used to
put it down on paper and you'll say that
you have these two characters gin and
king which one's stronger i would you
would automatically gravitate to the gin
but then it's it's obviously tekken is
not a game played on paper right so yeah
yeah yeah it it depends on if em he can
get devil rocky can get those mix-ups
and actually get into his head with the
throat game and then kind of get him to
duck and really mix him up it could be
bad but obviously rafe has actually been
very um
aggressive
in his play from our remember he's been
very aggressive so it's also about can
devil rocky keep him out what's his
what's king's good keep out tools now
back back one is a fast count hitting
launcher but the hitbox in it
not the best
yeah it will whiff so it's i think it's
about how he can keep rafe out it seems
like once rafe gets in that's when he's
a strongest
yeah for sure and i think that a really
important thing to see here is that uh
devil rocky doesn't doesn't get too um
flustered because you can clearly see
that the torment nerves are getting to
him in that last match he was not
breaking throws he was not punishing
really well he was committing to things
that he shouldn't have been committing
to uh you know looking at the level of
play that he we have seen him play at
before but we're going to be going to
the infinite stage here um and you know
no walls in play i don't know if this is
going to be in anyone's favor in
particular um just pure tekken head
bubsy yeah and you know what you know
i'm a fan of pure tech and i like the
purest of the pure technology stages
are like you know is it are they pure
characters though is king and are king
and jin pure characters you know i had
to i was gonna say you know when i was
talking about that i had to stop myself
because i don't
because obviously i want to keep my
opinions to myself
all right instantly going in with the
electric off to a quick start bro he
chose war who when you start off with an
electric you do not choose peace you
chose i want war bro like a million
miles an hour
wow
that is so unfortunate i had the right
idea there but maybe you just broke the
slide a little bit too shallow so yeah
and i think that wasn't intuitive would
have been a better way to go for that
nice launch here we go double rocky
finally get something started oh come on
dude what the hell i mean was that a mix
up i don't know maybe try to go for the
throw mix up there but rafe has seen
that before and the option just go for
the hot kick exactly mix up yeah i'll
put you matt blender
i mean that that one didn't go for a
tailspin there devil rock you're looking
very flustered head to start this match
i've arrived now running away with it
yeah like i mean we said this before
once he gets started i think this is
where he's at his strongest once he gets
that momentum going that wave that she's
moving at you know 100 miles an hour
yeah
he's just gonna run you over 100 man
he's looking but who the hell put this
guy loser i think luffy was the one who
put right if it loses but he's looking
like he's unstoppable right now he
definitely is you know he's in that
loser's bracket like he knows he's got
one life left maybe it just powers him
up maybe this is his power up you know
you have to be in losers
yeah yeah you know
some players are like that man we've
seen it a lot in the icfcs as well
people winning from the loser side but
that's affordable county and i should be
dead right
another no round brown can anyone stop
this man devil rocky on the back flip
bubsy it's just once he gets started it
i i don't know what can he do to stop
like he just looks so strong and i've
never seen so many axe kicks actually
hit from ginny's like he's really got
them to duck or flinch like you don't
really see it that much because the ice
kick is a slower mid launcher sometimes
people can dark and kind of react to it
and stand up in time but it seems to be
really in their head
yeah yeah for sure i mean he's just on
in the zone yeah sometimes you're just
in the zone man everything you do works
out for you he's playing very solid
tight second as well not giving many
opportunities for devil rocky to get the
to get the launches or any punishment
but when he does devil rocky doesn't
maximize on his opportunities and it's
because the pro i'm telling you it's got
to be nerves man it has to be you know
it's just like this is not what we're
used to seeing from devil rocky we we
know he's a lot stronger than this but
right is showing his experience he's
showing his composure and his tenacity
in tournaments and and he's i don't know
what the rocky hack has to do here man
yeah well
one he used to convert fully as you see
he got that launch he um he went for the
wrong combo then i guess he's tried to
make up for it and kind of over extend
and then went into that throw mix-up and
reyf was just not having it he just saw
that wave dash coming in he's like you
know what i'm gonna place this hot kick
right here and and it hit and in in that
sense it just all that momentum that um
he had it's gone now double rocky had no
more momentum now he's in the launch
situation he's in the okazemi and he's
back in rafe's game so he really needs
to capitalize when he gets these
opportunities he needs to capitalize get
that damage going and to oh
yeah i think he's decided man just to
switch to fuckerman this is the
character that we've seen him but we've
seen him play mark and tom we've seen
him play [ __ ] ramen tournament and
he's finally going for a different uh
pick here because the king just hasn't
been working up and you know there's
bubsy sometimes in tournament your main
character just doesn't work for you on
the day you have to switch it up yeah
he's going for the big boy from thailand
fakum ram can he make it work here we're
going to the duomo de syrio bellissimo
we're in italy uh you know saudi's going
at it i was actually hoping you'd say
that name because i was like i know that
i know the stage's name i see it all the
time but pronounce it i am so bad with
pronouncing i just really like saying it
is
serious
teach me teach me this
cereal
nice yeah do you know how i am with
languages when i go
yeah when we were in spain and you were
like i don't i remember that clearly we
were like at the uh supermarket and
they're like uh hola and then he's like
you're like hi
gracias thanks
those words i think i sound silly
like you gotta try these look look
listen listen i'm gonna say this bonjour
brother doesn't sound right bro how can
i say french words of the english accent
it just doesn't sound right i just
rather just say hi okay they'll respect
the the attempt though you know
bro i just i just feel like i've not
said it right bonjour
you know
what you're to that
holy [ __ ] look at this rocky looking so
different with the [ __ ] man finally
gets around on the board after how many
bloody rounds i mean yeah well good
stuff then the rocky baccarat is
definitely a scary character he's got a
huge damage out but he's a very strong
character even though he's been as we
put in quotations normalized he's still
a very strong character
oh that was a crispy whiff punish
all right there we go take a look at the
wall curry is this right okay this
starts working around don't know yeah
it's a 50 50 on other characters though
isn't it like if you back roll then it
hits you
oh my god kick jack kick oh that kick is
cool it's one of the ones that when you
get hit by it hurts it like stops time
and everything yeah oh try to go for the
rage drive but hit out of it with a jab
drive on the board now but this is
looking way better for double rocky
definitely he's looking more in this
game
okay
oh nice throw break there
looks like it's a late throw break as
well
nice oh
nice jesus rapist
that's the thing ray has the answers
when you get that momentum going he just
knows how to say no bro yeah i'm taking
this back right now
how many strings fuckerman has i think
that
jin can kind of parry against a lot of
them and and shut down the options right
yeah
need to be very careful rage is
available go to the rage drive now not
gonna be huge damage but what's the mix
up
oh nice patience on the floor there from
right he's staying on the floor a little
bit delayed his get up kick and now
rifle is on set point to eliminate
devrocky from the former but a nice
punishment back one again he just he
just knows how to stop people's momentum
like like he said great patience and he
even
waited like nope i know right now stop
your momentum
there we go this is a big combo though
nice carry
looking very nice punish there gets the
block punished gonna go towards the wall
nice he stops it knew he wasn't all
gonna hit great awareness oh boy
oh nice range drive out of nowhere devil
rocky taking it to a final round can you
get a match on the board bro the way
that rage right here i was gonna take
him back upstairs
upstairs you've never seen that before
nice combo
all right just shut up the wall
there's a beautiful punishment down by
four it is minus 14. yeah
goes into stops nice cancels it make it
safe
okay this is this is devil rocky's last
chance saloon needs this round to stay
in the tournament not like that they'll
have to punish
again he's making he's taking massive
risks here devil rocky
a bit of pressure now nice life brother
relatively even needs to be very careful
because he's done that performance
my god no way double rocky is he going
to get match on the board oh god
is that going to be it this should be it
yes uses the rage drive to maximize the
damage out there
that's so that's so sad because
devil rocky was he done so much better
there he started to you know get his
game back get his gameplay going but
just a bit i just fell short there you
know just hell sweet just went for it
you know rolled six on the dice
yeah i feel like i'm partly to blame for
that one i kind of uh kind of cursed him
there right sending him to johannes
straight away to oh again double rocky
man i feel like he made the right choice
to go for the [ __ ] ramen it was
definite i wish he would have made that
choice a bit earlier sometimes having a
second secondary character is
it's a good thing to have right but uh
double rocky a good performance to get
to um to where he got to that's a fifth
place finish for him the rife will move
on into the loser's semi-finals on next
match is going to be a big one it's
going to be md luffy who i felt like was
the favorite to win this tournament um
still alive in the loser side going up
against uh jordan muhammad
from uh from amman so i'm gonna be a
good one man yeah definitely like you
said you know sometimes when you're in
the goo like i mean that lua lua
twit longer bubsy said loser bracket
what an [ __ ] what an absolute villain
but yeah uh the lower bracket or loser's
bracket uh we have mohammed mishima yes
the ling versus versus the poor what do
you think about this one from
luffy ender so this is it's going to be
an interesting because you said luffy is
a character specialist and obviously
against ling
ling is a conventional tekken character
but she has these moves that kind of
break the rules these evasive moves so
it's it's more going to be a thing of
how luffy can deal with that but does he
know the options when when she
transitions into aop now
i'm not a pool uh expert but i'm
thinking down one it looks like a solid
move that's gonna hit and but like i'm
not the expert because aop just it goes
under loads and stuff so i don't know
yeah so it's it's a tough one but i feel
like um i think that saudi arabia has uh
very good uh linked players as well uh
there's one uh someone could probably
tell me in the in the in the chat at
home but um there's an eddie and link
player i forgot his name now for the
life of me it's gonna annoy me but uh
they've had some very strong link
players in saudi arabia as well so i'm
sure i'm a hundred percent sure that
luffy has um
some experience here in this matchup
let's see what you can do here it is
jordan versus saudi arabia let's get
into it yeah also ling's been a been one
of those characters that's been um i
guess strong and in a
strong character and potentially like
potential um tournament winning
character from season from even
pre-release i think
and so
i think you had to have some kind of
idea of the match up
just from in general
well let's see how luffy decides to play
this one man
okay nice little parry
gonna go towards the wall
and he's oh there you go using the aop
it was quite a basic on the back one
yeah oh big oh my god
that is a good that is pineapple chunks
and i cannot wait to get home because i
got some pineapple chunks on my protein
the pineapple chunks and sweet syrup
sweet serve the sweetest of the syrups
so you know you used to say this
probably that paul is the businessman he
gets the business you know he's a nine
to five guy clocks out as soon as five
hits bro he's not doing that over time
he wants to get that job done
over time no look at this demo man
oh boy all the time you're very strong
that's dead wow luffy now with a
confidence this is what this is what
we're more used to seeing from luffy
right definitely
nice i like that stuff maybe standard
freeze is a good art size you know that
looks like it's got a really low um
hitbox yeah
he's using it a lot just to like you
know keep ling out and i guess it would
be the aop as well so an option that
he's using here very well and he's got a
massive likely look at that seen it
again oh that was a that was a cheeky um
death fist he was that's what i'm saying
he meant to clock out bro he's like it's
4 59
i need to clock this out right now i
need to get out of here
let's see if you can get out of here
right now 30 seconds on the clock no
break on that back 10 throw okay nice
patience there to get up correctly
oh you could have let it rip yeah that
could have been big damage there
okay a little bit slow
but i guess luffy's in a good position
where link is not in rage um territory
like rage yet yeah yeah
just outside of rage and they didn't
make it so that you know you have to
have
less life to get into rage and look at
that five seconds left on the clock the
rage drive gets punished with the
standing three again and did you see
that opposite it looks like it has a
little bit of tracking just to the right
which is perfect for aop so i feel like
that is the anti-aop move which uh he's
using really well as keypad versus link
he def like i said he knows the matchup
he knows what he needs to do his options
and on the on the flip side with the
pressure that luffy's been applying
there were opportunities for muhammad to
get the the launches with the death face
and other big whiffs but he wasn't
taking them that's what happens when you
when you get flustered yeah um so before
the match that was talking about like
luffy needs to know the key moves to
using its thing and i was i said thought
about down one but no it seems like
standing three you know you can see if
it hits as well you can go into three
two so even more damage there and i
think yeah that one here it is quite
advantageous like it's definitely your
goal again um i think it's really high
numbers so um
like it looks like he's done his
homework he he knows what to do and yeah
it's really showing he's looking
comfortable and ling is a character once
you're uncomfortable she starts getting
into her mix up her smick stops and
hitting you with those lows and you're
uncomfortable it's it's long for man
let's just say it we'll keep it london
it's just long yeah there's a lot of a
man yeah definitely we've seen it as
well with people like mr croft in europe
terrorizing icfc with that link
especially when they get started with
all the all the dancing all the flippy
floppies and spinneys you know it's just
crazy but look at that no no no flippy
floppies anymore he's going straight to
the horrung you know knowing that luffy
was just too comfortable versus the link
not letting him get anything started and
now we're gonna potentially get another
type of vortex you know the horung
strings yeah are we going to get them
harry on the infinite as your two are
gonna be the most beautiful stage in
tekken have you got added in season two
let's go yeah actually this is a fun
fact this this actually wasn't season
one but you have to have the vr i'm sure
i had a video yes
i remember when you went uh you invited
me to the namco yeah in the uk and i was
able to try out the vr i'm like wow this
is cool and it was this stage i'm sure
it was it was yeah see people may not
know that taught you a little something
this stage was actually there from
before that's crazy i didn't even think
about that but have you got luffy nice
down four two that muhammad can probably
get something started but no walls are
in play okay okay he's
he may not be playing ling but the
mix-ups are still strong
oh boy oh boy no no duck yeah that's he
could have ducked that there
he's back he's gonna get oh i thought
he's gonna run all the way in is he
gonna run a little bit
oh oh oh oh oh
i lost my breath
i couldn't breathe
i couldn't breathe why
he that was such a bait he he put the
the worm on the hook he reeled it out
there and just left it he ran straight
in thinking you're getting um a
blockable charge but then you use this
power crush then no bro i'm poor i'm
clocking out it's five
no break of the throw okay here we go
i'm liking this the this one
yeah hold on
oh nice big car hit it's gonna be chunky
damage
okay close to the demo man
range available now oh trying to get the
power crash oh no on bar hits him
on that's it catches him with the crouch
that's three luffy's just looking so on
point
are you serious magic four back one two
look at this from luffy blue sparks he
is definitely feeling himself right now
he's comfortable he looks comfortable
now
yeah okay but as i say that gets a big
car here
yeah
nice nice combo okay nice it gets a
little bit momentum
reminisce in his chin
yeah he's got the jail facades but luffy
just poking away in his face now gets a
live lead backing off a little bit
trying to keep hold of it
very back and forth right now luffy one
hit away potentially
nice
that move is so good
it's scary as well because you could be
pressing buttons and you know you're
going to get hit because it it absorbs
absorbs your moves
absolutely and he tried to go for the
sidestep moves on his homing so
luffy now again with a lot of momentum
trying to finish this early
nice time in the downfall too there gets
the full launch
yep okay what's the mix up oh my big
whiff
yeah that was optimal back free
okay nice punishment
oh
that could be dead with the rage can he
finish it though
nice
yes
wow no way just like that
every single time luffy is like so close
to winning mohammed mishma brings it
back with a horror can he finish it now
and take it to a final match i hope it's
not going to be like one of them meme
videos where someone's like running the
100 meter hurdles and this is dropping
the last hurdle over there in the league
oh no
mohammed bishop is the momentum now but
you can never count paul out man paul
has so much damage potential
he can always bring it back nice
blocking the law seems like he has a
good ring now a little bit slow on that
launch and punish with the duck
jabs oh no he's in the vortex now
we've got rage available nice dark
ladies and lads mohammed mishima with a
reverse sweep is going to take you to a
final match
luffy
is he going to be eliminated hitting the
loser bracket and go home with fifth
bubbles from jordan mohammed mishima a
switch to the horror from ling no like
um i did this was unexpected i i didn't
know he played harangum
and it looked like it was um curtains it
looked like you know luffy had control
of that match as well but
all of a sudden like i said but the
reverse sweep um
seems like he's he settled a bit now you
know that's definitely going to settle
him he's got some momentum he's broken
that you know it was tournament point he
was playing i'm not talking about points
so i set point he was he was there was
tournament his tournament live and it
seemed like he just got that power up he
seemed like he had the right answers and
he just took took the match back a bit
like hold on you know paul you're doing
some overtime today mate yeah this is
this look
jordan was supposed to have a master
event in 2020 before this little virus
came along and did his thing right and
you know jordan having having a look at
them with the fake invitational
everybody could see the pakistanis the
koreans everyone that was there could
see just how strong this community was
for such a small scene 20 people i was
talking to these guys when i was there
they said we know i was seeing it
consists of about 20 people and but we
are coming we're committed we're
passionate and we love this game so much
that we just we meet up all the time
when we play and we just grind out the
game this is why these guys are so
strong right and
and it's great to see that these guys
are competing right now going up against
i'll give you one of the best one of the
best players in the world with luffy and
he's taking it to a final match with not
even his main character so here we go
georgian versus saudi arabia let's go
horuk versus paul
what did that say he blocked the low and
it looked like this
the ice kicks with i wonder if that's a
a specific matchup thing
maybe you'll see maybe luffy will take
that um into consideration earlier but
as i said that gets hit with a down four
two gets caught stepping
yeah i think luffy is in a bit of
autopilot mode right now he was
sidestepping into a button and he got
caught but have you gone out a big
opportunity for damage yeah against the
wall oh god this is going to do
so much damage that new wall ends up
from paul it does chunks again on the
back of the head
doesn't um that time that's one of those
moves like
you get caught by it more often um than
you should
yeah
i like that it's a good quarter from
luffy to know that muhammad was gonna go
for a move at the start of the round
sometimes very very easy way to open up
your opponent just notice to see if
they'd like to press buttons at the
start of the round easy back dash into
launch
yeah nice sidewalk oh that's a great
conversion on the combo but was it it
looked a little bit funky
a lot of pressure and that should be it
now yeah so this is this is um a very
peculiar situation here because this is
what happened last time
luffy was very comfortable had the two
rounds and then mohammed mishima just
literally just got the power up
yeah this is where he started to wake up
man but look at some loopy her character
specialist he knows all the situations
nice adaptation and a wall to his back a
breakable wall not a place you want to
be in nice downfall to keep up though
make sure he's bringing it back again
bob z
okay my horizons going the wrong way you
know oh do a u-turn mate
okay nice have them in the water oh
it gets the next one
is this gonna be it look at damage plus
frames and again
that was actually kind of scary he
needed to take back the momentum because
it's one of the technical techniques
it's not just a fighting game played on
the pad it is also a mental game now he
he's seen
that happen before but you know talking
about seeing it happen before let's just
let's just we can see ourselves i don't
have to talk to you guys
yeah so this was the the the match again
alright versus devil rocky and we said
that rife was most likely going to go in
with the with a quick start right
because he was just playing so solidly
and then devil rocky brought something
out that he wasn't expecting the the
[ __ ] rum which he had which we have
seen in playing torment before yeah but
i think it was just too little too late
he finished it off sending him to
johannam there with the sweep and uh yes
that was rife moving on and then here we
go luffy like so comfortable that's a
link very comfortable even back dashed
out this is this was so sick that was he
just
that was so sick but as he said he was
two rounds up here and it just seemed
like he i don't know if he just took his
foot off the pedal but muhammad mishama
are there with a great combat great
combo they're using the rage um
yeah
but then yeah here we go this is the end
of the match and just with that yeah
plus frames plus frames
there's not a lot you can do that kind
of situation really it's just you have
to eat that pressure you know you're
back against the wall it's one of the
worst positions to be in the second
especially that corner you sidestep one
way so that's the other way still
against the wall
yeah good position in the corner there's
tough and you know that it all came from
a side step was it sidestep three yeah
you know that low on counter here gives
the free back one too and then he
sidestep to get the rear wall spout and
it's like damn the damage and that's
what you get when you are a character
specialist right it might seem
insignificant but the fact that he only
really plays paul in tournament and he
just grinds out that character so much
he knows every little scenario that you
know because when you play thousands of
thousands and thousands of matches with
that character you know every situation
you know that okay in this situation
with this kind of float i can do this
now with this combo at this in this
corner this is what i can do so you know
this is what we're seeing a really
optimized poor hair from luffy so it's
no surprise that he's going to be moving
on into our losers uh semi-finals i
believe um and you know but big shout
outs to um to mohammed mishima and a
massive shout out to all of the
jordanian scene man you know i love you
guys i miss you guys uh we were gonna i
was gonna be there for 2020 a lot of
people are going to come to you but keep
on grinding keep on doing your thing and
inshallah soon we're all going to be
there in jordan enjoy some good ass
second together but yes uh saudi arabia
israel and georgia are the last remains
i believe we will be going into our
winners finals next bubsy oh this is
this is a you know a tasty treat before
we get into that
yeah we're gonna see yes so these are
all the like you said we said this
before this is such a this is the beauty
of this it's an online it's global look
at all these regions it's just such a
great representation of the globe
and like we even had africa um added
this year to west africa it's been it's
doing an amazing um
amazing turnaround this year actually
for the amount of regions that's been
represented here
yeah yeah definitely man and we're
seeing players and people are learning
about different talented players around
the world which you haven't been able to
see before uh using online i know it's
not the best environment but i'm
actually happy that we have this so
happy because um we've been able to
learn about people that we didn't know
about before and then offline we'll be
able to see them compete with the with
the weights off so to speak right you
know when like piccolo takes off his
team and it's like yeah you know full-on
weights off you know um and of course
this immediately today south asia
southeast asia philippines east asia
ocean and korea and japan coming up uh
and from a lot of those regions there's
gonna be players like especially in
southeast asia not a lot of you guys are
gonna know about these guys south asia
as well of course so so much to look
forward to of course um but if you do
want to enter these tournaments and try
to get some points it doesn't matter how
many points you get if you do not
register yourself and be part of the
leaderboards you see the link there make
sure that you register um on the portal
the esports tournament portal and if you
do not do that then your points won't
really matter man you have to register
uh and of course if you are a tournament
organizer then online dojo applications
will end on october 10 so make sure that
you get your your tournament um uh your
application submitted and then you can
be part of the tech online challenge
definitely you know like i said october
the 10th we are september 19th and ty
has just been flying by you know we just
time warped time skip so that is
no time so like spike says make sure you
submit your applications um yeah in time
basically yeah absolutely and of course
then follow the uh social medias as well
be any esports on twitter and youtube
and of course follow uh tekken at
twitter twitch and facebook to keep up
to date with everything happening in the
tekken world
ladies and gents i believe we are going
to be moving into our winners finals
it's going to be uh
complain versus ultra instinct
a tasty treat we were talking about um
food earlier was talking about starters
this is definitely like we're getting
the heart of the meal now this is the
meat with the gravy
like you know this is the main this is
this is going to be
as jr from wrestling used to say a
slobber knock right it's going to be a
good one it's going to be one hell of a
match here we're going to have ultra
instinct patel using that king versus
complain who was my boy let me just say
that
yeah i forgot how i forgot how you're
right most of the time this is the thing
i've learned over the years never doubt
bubsy man but yeah it's going to be
potato from georgia versus uh complained
from israel um
we're going to the chicago pali pad this
i've never seen that view of g fight
before what the hell that's crazy um
but yeah uh yoshi vs king a very unique
matchup once again not one that we see
often yeah yeah it's def yeah like you
said it's not one we see often but in
the fact contain just
like i said chose war today started off
so strong he is not letting go of king
big whip on the fourth floor
and i believe these guys have played
quite often as well um in grand finals
in a lot in in tournaments so they're
going to have knowledge against each
other so uh a complaint started off
perfectly there seven golden letters see
i wanted i wanted to make the worst that
joke ever but i think what was the dad
joke i was like complain can't complain
with those seven calling letters
we're getting old
bro so many people are you know
followers now so you know that jokes may
apply
eleven win streak here four complain
let's see if we can keep that up
okay
patel using that trying to catch him
crouching
he's using a lot of mids here you know
trying to keep him check make sure he
stays respectful doesn't move too much
yeah
and talking about respect there's no
respect for frozen out there
oh nice duck
yeah this is gonna go to the wall oh god
this is a bad position to be in
okay wait for some kind of setup doesn't
really work out but still does have the
rage available you need to be very
careful king's race drive is one of the
best in the game up there he's out he's
definitely up there
holy nice
all right complain now two rounds up a
very experienced yoshimitsu playing the
play for many many a year yeah just look
at that movement it's so slick oh no
break on the shining wizard though
yeah
okay nice okay nice dark now that string
is it's a tricky yoshi thing like you
need to be on point and ready for it
because if you press the button too late
and dark you will get count and hit
launch
yeah
this is a much better round here for
ultra interpretation looking to make a
perfect little call out on the spin yeah
using the homing move on the board now
here so that is one of the things that
when you when you're fighting against
the yoshi in this match up spin
obviously it evades it evades a lot
quicker than a side step besides walk
but holding moves will hit it
okay now close the flash where's the
wall ah there's a wall
okay got no source nothing goes to that
seat it's a full launch
okay it goes to the other wall this guy
is a definite character specialist
finding all those walls
that was unfortunate
oh no i could have let it rip that would
have been big damage oh what the hell's
going on here i don't know what's going
on people's elbow what's the mixture
oh
such a big read there but it doesn't pay
off
ah
he he thought he had the answer there
because
he thought that you were going to stay
on this ground
and you know it would have been the
round he would run he would have won
that round that was such a big read um
yeah i don't agree with he could have
gone for like a down three maybe to stay
a little bit safer but
yeah but i think that in that situation
you know he was looking to get the uh
the win sometimes when you're when you
have such a massive life deficit you
have to take risks right true and i
think in his in his mind he was like
okay i've got to keep on taking risks
even though at the end he kind of didn't
have to right but um he was in like
panic mode he was in fight or flight
mode you know he's like okay i need to
go i need to go with him
ultra instinct you know it was an ultra
instinct it didn't work for me it didn't
it wasn't perfect to alter anything it
wasn't the white hair it was the it was
like okay
unfortunately
and i actually kind of missed super you
know i know people didn't like it uh you
know what you know what before people
start canceling me again like
i'm not an anime specialist all right i
just i didn't watch it like because i
know people get really get into it and
they're like no but his power level was
this yesterday like no i just watched it
but as it was didn't it like i i
instantly just watched it
and i enjoyed it all right it was like i
got a lot there was a lot of complaints
i thought oh the art wasn't good
please don't shoot me down guys i
enjoyed it okay please please laugh you
gotta cancel again how dare you calling
at the lower bracket now you're saying
db super was good twit longers guys
everybody twitter oh please allow me i'm
new to this i'm just coming back please
i like that all right here we go
we're on the uh the howard estate now
let's see what um ultra instinct can do
here this is a stage that actually if
they don't go for the forgotten realm
they actually do end up going to this
one so let's see we'll make a difference
you get amazing combos on this stage
especially you know with those three
wall bases very unique stage in the
sense that i don't think they've ever
seen a tekken stage with three wall base
oh gosh keeps it going yeah they kept
going
okay look at that that's the massive
difference right we didn't see that in
the in potatoes last match against devil
um
but yeah he wasn't he wasn't breaking
those throws
okay okay oh here we go now this is now
this is a three-way mix-up okay goes for
the sharp shooter this time because i'm
a nerd i know that's a one break
okay nice
is that could you break that because it
was um yeah
so in that situation i think with that
back turn with that grounded throw he
gets another
attempt
so i think that other temple's
guaranteed if i remember correctly i
haven't played king and ages
okay nice looking better hair for ultra
potatoes
those ground floors really worked out
there
yeah it's funny because that's how we
lost a match last round um game you
going for that ground bro
nice and you know that hop knee it not
only crushes lows but it has a bit of
height evasion as well and look at that
beautiful complaint back on the board
even in it out here
straight back with that that was a solid
round complaint take it back take that
momentum back from ultramarine doesn't
want him to get anything started
yeah okay down back three okay okay go
through hopkins try to keep him honest
see if he's was respecting the downward
three plus frames
[Music]
straight into that
now do you see how he sidestepped as
well to kind of realign himself with
yeah it was really good and i like the
way he kept the combo nice and short
make sure he got the guaranteed damage
there
okay now punish
complains okay completely trying to back
away from the wall
okay but
and this should be around yet keep it
nice and simple go to the running
problem ender
round four oh yeah really just answering
back
i'm liking this
count to hit the start off this round
now ultra interpreter will be able to
take this into the corner here now this
is a very dangerous position for
competitiveness he guesses wrong on that
as well fifty percent got it here comes
the chain throw oh oh russian left sweep
he's gonna go for the arm bar
oh no what's the mix up you guys oh
because let me hear okay oh get caught
on the second hit is this gonna be seven
golden lev
okay
patience
there so in that situation
yoshi can keep doing i think it's crouch
one he can keep doing that and he'll
keep flipping but i guess he thought
that he's gonna tech because if he if he
goes through that crash dash one and you
text it's basically you're you're gonna
get launched because he's gonna take it
you're mad open but if you take it
you're gonna take straight into that
sweet so he's playing that mind game
right there saying that i think you're
not going to stay on this ground you're
going to take because you don't want to
eat this so
let me i'm gonna hit you with this tech
trap but you guessed right there on the
okay yeah and of course that flip over
the crash dash one cd1 it didn't do a
lot of damage anyway it doesn't hurt too
much and you had a massive lifeline yeah
i'll just stay on the floor if he tries
to go for one of the other options to
catch my tech roll then it's going to be
an easy punish and i'll get the round so
yeah i mean like i said one thing about
ultra insane potato is he's a very clean
player he makes he just stays composed
and he makes really good decisions
because he's just a experienced player
you saw how many matches he's got in
just playing match we don't even count
ranked that's just playing man that's
just the player match yeah and that's
just wins not even losses not even kind
of the losses right so thousands and
thousands of matches and of course
the georgian scene is a scene that is
definitely going to break out offline
soon because they not only have
alternative they have a lot of other
very strong um players as well you know
very very fundamentally solid players
and their offline scene is is pretty
strong just like i was talking about
jordan how they have a small offline
scene georgia has the same thing um so
that's why we're seeing these guys you
know compete here in the top level
yes i'm talking about this is definitely
top level games here because
me i love to see the mind games in the
middle man games and we saw it there at
the end of that match where you know it
was just deeper than technology it's
just you know we're really getting into
the mental mind games there and that's
when i think tekken is at his best fight
yeah so here we go
all right there we go complain starting
off stronghood one match apiece the
throws coming out here from potato and
it's the first reaction here now because
it's winners finals what's going to be
the okie dokie well so jericho goes to
the ground floor again but doesn't wake
up in time
nice sidestep hockey that's the second
time he's done that means be successful
but misses on the fourth floor one tail
spin there
yep
but okay nice on the spin but it was
very patient there didn't press the
button
[Music]
dancing how how did he how did he um oh
he's pro breaking is really good i i
would have got caught by that dancing
100 yeah 100 the reason why that giant
is so hard to break is especially after
a dash is because it looks very similar
to a shining wizard right so a lot of
people press one plus two because i
think it's a running running throw i i
would have pressed one plus two i would
have eaten yeah i would have got front
across the stage nice phrasing just
correctly on the three-way mix-up
[Music]
okay oh
charging up
yes
so you can punish that but if you if
you're a little bit delayed you're gonna
get counter hit right there you need to
be on point there ultra into the tail
just wasn't ready there i would have
been ready for that either he just kind
of threw it out there you know yeah
quite sleeping at the wheel yeah talking
about i talked about throwing out there
here comes the launch it drops it again
the forward forward one he's dropping
his combo set nice back dash but it
doesn't get
he could have got a hot knee there but
you know any damage is better than no
damage there and again on four three
looking to end the round
oh no no
complain for the comeback caught by the
rage drive right there using the plus
strains before and then using the range
drive to lock them down like rage drives
have a really big hurt box so it's it's
they're kind of hard to step
yeah no we're harder to step let's say
that you can't
okay we're seeing good movement here
from potato sidewalking left which is
the way you want to go generally versus
yoshimitsu you know
here you go for the giant i'm not
dancing that's the irish rig
of course for the half boston crab
because i'm a nerd and i know these
moves you know the movements
[Music]
all right
all right oh it drops the combo again
get caught coming in with the flash it's
going to be huge damage
yep two tailspins here because the rage
drive is even out no punish he was off
axis
sword sweep complain like i said this
man has many many tricks up his sleeves
complaining bringing them out now it
just seemed like he he was just the fan
favorite in that scramble you got a
little bit
what
caught it oh yeah what an answer there
with the running power bomb
oh god all right now we've got a bit of
a brawler this is what we wanted to see
man okay come get out of that bro if if
you didn't get out of it then i i would
have been it wouldn't mean hashtag pay
for cam complain code
there we go and that nice what's the mix
up
okay uses the rage drive there
yeah that's good good stuff on complain
i mean from our potato just making him
erase his resources yeah
because it's scary as well because when
you shoot who does have the um
braids he actually is one of the unique
characters that has access to two um
rage art and one of them is a flash
yeah yeah yeah nice well i'm talking
about flash there he went for a flash
but um
also it's a potato being very patient
there i was able to punish you
okay a little twitch stuff from
complaining just like hit by them throws
a nice break on the giant so again
complain really showing this good throw
breaking yeah he's saying that he's
really on point there like king's froze
like they they really do wear you down
and you're not gonna really gonna break
them all
yeah
and is that hey
it's not gonna bring them all go
subjecting doesn't tech though
yeah so it doesn't um lessen the damage
when you tech you lessen the damage
oh
no what are you trying to heal for bruh
bro why are you trying to heal nice okay
as well rage available complain can you
make another comeback
he's done it before
don't turn your back on me all right
punish ten nice
there you go guys goes for no sword so
you need to be very careful flash
because i think flash comes out a little
bit faster than this or has a bigger
hurt but it's one of the two
nice
i will take my left foot and just put it
in your face you can't do this nice
upward three beautiful so again you can
see around like complain clearly is is
playing really well as well not playing
bad by any means excellent but i'll
drink the potato once again the decision
making the timing is looking very good i
would like to see him punish a little
bit better um because of course there
are moves like cd1 which you mentioned
is launch punishable but
you know you need to have a move which
has good range to punish it maybe kings
forward two would be a better oh yeah
there's me trying to move down is that's
one of his new moves is new additions
there's a great addition actually um
that was a great one i was thinking back
three but now four two yeah no
definitely not that it's a four
traveling
chunky it's a it's a mid right yeah as
well yeah so uh yeah that would be a
great move to use just to whiff punish
in general because it looks like he's a
little bit attentive he's like i don't
want to go for my hop kick punish in
certain scenarios because it might with
well for two if you're any it's kind of
confirmable as well in situations it's
like situational confirmable yeah so
that would be a bit better but complain
i i feel like we might be getting a
final match chamber because complain
definitely has a lot more tricks up the
sleeve might be going to an in uh a wall
stage again just to utilize the the old
key mix up stuff
um yoshimitsu when he gets when he gets
to the wall he's got an oaky baby tech
he's got the sword windmill and then
like he said before we stay on the
ground he's got the crash that's one and
it just becomes a bad
oh match but
what you said bob z this is what you
said man he does have a pool and
it was it was only this week he was
actually playing kanan trench
and kanan trench is one of our strongest
players won many a tournament before and
it was really back and forth
it was really really really back and
forth so it's gonna be interesting to
see um paul like i said that character
it causes a scary character like there's
no one that can tell me that plays tech
and then they're not scared of a pool
when you see a pool in your bracket
you're like
there we go today you know
it could go either way like big man hits
yeah but if you're ultra if you're
potato right now you're thinking you
know what i have the advantage here
because i'm winning on on matches and
i've made him such character so
definitely in the driver's seat at the
moment oh he's driving that was a great
duck there with the full crouch um um
down board too it's gonna be oh the wall
splat on the hot kick unfortunately
okay nice patience there from ultra
instant potato just avoiding everything
so goku esque i want to say here we
oh go because yeah that is a punish
there is it how is that not clean here
yeah that should be a polish right
that was a punishment yeah yeah yeah
this is weird that it wasn't a it wasn't
a clean kick there i think it's a war i
think it's an angle yeah a weird angle
on the wall you know how walls are boo
ki you know yeah you know
what the booty rocks have you got four
i'm trying to go for a a a throw
well this guy's playing super solidly
right now nice side step two
this should go to the wall
nice gets curry
oh that was sick version so when you
when you get that side wall if you do
one two and he's like ground throw it
works as a combo
i learned that from aries actually
yeah
okay rage available for potato now good
break that was clutch break
no if you get punished there gets a side
wall splat
so unfortunate
and and that's the thing about king's
back one man it's got a bit of let you
see it again right it's hitbox is not
the best it's definitely not the best
like because it's it's a good car
hitting tool but
it can get a bit finicky and just get
punished it looks like
complain now it's just all over it looks
like this whole pic made
maybe the answer i'm telling you paul is
scary he's a scary character for sure
man i mean he's doing really well in
this scramble situations and now
potatoes overextending he's getting
nervous bubsy definitely nice sidestep
just messes up the combo okay hop kick
nice punch on that need to be very
careful because that is a wall break
right there
oh we tried to break the ball i think
okay that sounds very unfortunate
oh no oh no oh no oh no one more hit no
oh
ladies and gents we are going to be
going to a final round potato one round
away from moving into grand finals here
for this master event he committed that
was a
big commitment at the beginning nice
slow oh get that [ __ ] out of here man
nice low parry there we go
okay walks are pushing towards the wall
good position but no he puts himself to
the wall this is a very bad position
he's gonna get old no doesn't get a wall
splat but king's in a very bad position
gets the wolf's back now
yeah
oh yes complain oh it doesn't get the
wool combo
and just go slow power crush that was
i had my i was like this that the
camera's gonna see i had my i didn't
want to see us i was scared wow just
coming back right there
making that what did that what did i say
man i feel like i said i feel like we're
going to be going to a final match
because it wouldn't be a master event
without that man winners finals are
going to a first to one now bubsy the
matches have been played out the
information has been downloaded
what does ultra instinct potato do now
the paul is out does he go back to the
howard and say does he go to the
forgotten realm or is it going to be an
infinite stage i mean what the choice is
very important now it all comes down to
this one match do you think it's i think
i don't know it's a good i'm thinking
about it like so it wasn't as if it was
like one-sided it was very part-mouth
clutch moments there
does he maybe he wants to give himself
to that little bit of an advantage maybe
go to the forgotten realm just so you
can get the big damage you know if he
gets the launch straight into um running
power bomb that's like unskilled damage
and then you get this um the tail spin
after but then again we've said this
before it's a double-edged sword
sometimes sometimes you want to live by
the sword you want that advantage
but then you could die by that advantage
as well you know like say paul you i'm
not really familiar i think paul gets
hit his downfall one plus two throw
actually becomes the launch right
yeah so i mean the thing is poor like in
that situation looking at the match like
how many times
the war messed him up even when he tried
to go for a back one the wall kind of
gave him a bit of a shove and then the
back one whiffed and like in so many
situations it wouldn't surprise me if he
goes to forgotten realm would a state or
even an infinite state here because um
he just wants to get rid of that
completely get rid of the walls and play
pure tekken that's what the koreans say
all the time koreans say well if i feel
like i'm better than you at tekken i'm
going to an infinite state statement
just outplay use it's a it's a statement
yeah it's it's a statement and i agree
like you know
that is i personally think that's the
purest form of tekken you know just and
if they chose such a good stage for it
you know with the the waters and that's
pure open stage but yeah this i i can't
actually call this match this this next
one is literally neck and neck you saw
it was a
king started with that down one plus two
he wanted war like i said when people
start with big boy launchers like that
they do not want peace they don't want
it you can see man like potato he's
always so controlled so calculated but
at the end there he started to whiff
massively yeah like i think the nerves
can get to anyone right even though he's
so composing he's been in tournaments
he's been in grand finals before he's
won tournaments he won an icfc
when georgia was allowed to compete in
the icfc's yep and
you know
he's terrorized a lot of people with his
with his king right but it's because
he's so controlled and fundamental but
even then when complaining he's
experienced that's one thing that's
coming oh yes you can definitely see his
experience
and he made him he made him falter but
here we go guys what is going to be the
decision what is going to be the
decision here for ultra into potato such
an important one he'll probably be
sticking with the king but what stage is
it going to be going to the g corp
helipad okay
i respect it
it does have the um the wall breaks on
both sides it is a
it's a
it's quite it's quite a large stage once
you get the the um the two windows
broken it's also quite uniquely shaped
stage as well so you can get some nice
combos where it's like side wall splat
and then you can get the next wall so
it'll be quite interesting and we've
seen he's like he's done it for a reason
for sure yeah and we've seen it before
because he's had the combos he's got the
sidewalls that he's done double jabs
into the um crouch throw which actually
combos into
you see it's a situation that that bumps
you where you know you whiff and the
four two one from king would have been a
perfect punisher right and we're not
seeing that right now from potato
nice giant swing i have respect that
wake up giants think um complains not
expecting so much damage uses the plus
frame catches him stepping with the
forward four oh oh oh this is why
dangerous oh gosh
this is gonna do a lot of damage and
with pull alright that was a clutch
break
good job keep out okay this
this is next hit com
play needs to be very careful both guys
the next hit will basically win and he
uses i think that's a punish there yeah
that was pointless i feel like that's
very polished about it i don't know why
he did that but either way you can see
on this stage i feel like paul has the
advantage almost because you can break
those about those those um those walls
yeah with the demo man right yeah yeah
that's all he's gonna be careful
definitely once he gets run paul gets
you back on a breakable wall it is um
literally
resetting for shout outs to
show you staying down for this one uh
messy guessing bro you used to unless
you guessed it
bro is that you just you can't you just
don't know what to do oh
he's very careful yes he knows about
that nice i love that from complain stay
patient yeah it's like in that situation
if you tech like nine times out of ten
you're going to get moved in your back
so you need to be very careful how you
get up in that situation ultra
inseparable he i think i think he's got
the white hair goku now he he's
definitely stepped it up
yeah he's he's making decisions that
don't make sense to us but they're
working out for him man no break on that
throw all trains a potato nice
okay but complain definitely not out of
this nice side sit there evasive throw
gets to the wall big damage here
okay needs to be very careful like we
said before because of the duck there oh
my god okay [ __ ] went on four two one
where is it there it is there we go
oh whoa whoa
oh no i thought he's gonna really wall
splat again
potato what a comeback
beautiful clutch there three runs
straight will move into the grand finals
bubsy damn that that shining wizard was
so instant just came out like complain
was just
not not ready for it
let's let's just go back let's let's see
that again i need to see this again
amazing what okay a very good start
there from complaining you know he took
the first match and went to the howard
estate and this is where aldrin's potato
started to bring it back you know the
infinite stage definitely actually it
was the choice from complain but it
worked out a lot better for uh potato
again you just see those clutch blocks
on the low and then upward three to
finish it off this is the end this is
what we saw here i thought it was gonna
be another one i thought was gonna see a
a proper combo video i thought it was
gonna do it all the way down to the end
but there's a block on the low and that
was
so crispy you know while standing fours
have a lot of frame advantage
kept him locked down instant while um
running throw isw and
just you know in that clutch moment he
just wasn't ready for it just didn't
expect it
yeah absolutely man and uh that now
means as you can see on the screen that
the grand finals is going to be occupied
by our boy ultra interpreter from
georgia on the winner's side yeah we'll
do move to the loser final so right now
we are in our top four there are two
saudi arabians one georgian and one
israeli here we've got diversity here
ladies and gentlemen online challenge
master event um presented by astro and
you know it's it's interesting because
the clutch factor i'm seeing here for
ultra into potato it's it's something
that you see in very experienced players
and yeah even though i believe i don't
know how new he is to tekken like
there's a lot of strong plays that we
have in in in tekken now that started in
second seven but it's just amazing to
see how strong he is and how fundamental
how composed you can be in these clutch
situations yes and one actual thing that
i want to bring up is he is currently
the leader in the rankings right yes
so he's already sitting pretty he's
guaranteed um
220 points right if i done the mass
correctly second place so that means
that no matter what happens here
the the lowest he can get is second
place and he he already has 95 points
points so he'll most likely be number
one on the leaderboard yeah
pretty even if he loses sitting very
pretty you know feet up i've actually
got my shoes off and i'm i'm sitting
pretty as well yeah
he's killing him
get comfortable ladies and lads because
our next match is going to be the losers
semi-finals it's an all saudi affair
here rife versus luffy paul versus jyn
this is just classic tekken characters
right here man
definitely definitely definitely um
i mean if these matches are anything to
go by we're going to be in for another
hellacious match right about that word
hellacious you know
yeah i get all these terms from watching
wrestling from back in the day i mean
the commentators and resting back them
they were hyped they were using these
high these hype words and i was like
yeah just uh crazy stuff man and
complain uh i wonder this match because
luffy like his last match against
muhammad was really strong was very
solid managed to make it and make a
comeback against the gorong but raith
man two this guy's been and it's the
person who put him into loser bracket
was actually luffy uh oh so this is the
double jeopardy
yeah yeah
there's double jeopardy here so luffy
was the one who put rife into losers um
and i'm sure that they have a lot of um
history against each other and it was a
2-0 as well it wasn't even two-on-one
2-0 so um luffy who was my pick to win
to you know go all the way um can he
potentially get his run back against
complain because complain was the one
who played yeah
that's how i was about to mention next
that it's just this whole thing's gonna
come back full circle in it so
yeah it could we could have another
winner's semi-final in the losers final
to meet ultra into the tail but let's
not get too ahead of ourselves
yes you've got this loser semi-final in
a minute to
to commentate you know yeah and you know
what you can't get comfortable you know
if you're altering the potato the amount
of times we've seen people win the grand
finals from the losers side you know
it's it's it's happened far too many
times for you to be comfortable sitting
there so uh let's see who's going to
continue on into this top top three
ladies and lads saudi versus saudi yola
we're going to the howard estate it's
rife versus luffy poor versus gin
let's see if we can go downstairs and
see some sacrilege tesco yeah we haven't
actually seen that today we haven't seen
them break all the way down
yeah
[Music]
you're nice to start off a little bit
poking like you said before these are
two
well i guess yeah literal these are
tekken characters you know jin was a
poster boy paul bin in tekken
yeah
and look at that man like uh rifle once
again off to a very strong start yeah
just to reiterate this is the best of
three so it's not um a best of five just
yet after when you get to the winners
and the finals that's when it is best of
three so this is the first or two
yes
okay
and if you're working on this comeback
i like this patient from luffy just
backing out that was a big whiff they
could have got something a little bit
more than a jab but you know probably
wasn't ready for that
yeah nice block spanish perfect punish
there from luffy um
yeah he uses it so well because it is
plus on on block i believe yeah it's
great
it really conditions you to not don't
look at that downforce once conditions
you not to duck and then just just
bullies you with the lows yeah
nice with punish there
okay down jab wanting to alleviate all
that pressure feel like lucy was getting
a bit too much momentum there
yeah
oh wow
oh wow that was a
am i going to do something
dad these guys are on another level
right now man
sometimes because they're in the zone oh
that's a bit okay over with nice stuff
from the race drive
wavy wave these threats against the wall
needs to be very careful uh one more
stack could change the whole momentum of
this round but luffy using those jabs as
keep out round four yeah same print now
two rounds up to one
yep very very good stuff there luffy two
rounds in a row now you gotta get
yourself away from that wall though that
breakable wall yes i'm sure race knows
those combos
we've seen so many combo videos where
the people break all three of those
walls and go downstairs as well be very
careful it's huge damage as well pretend
yeah anyway
luffy pain very patient he does have the
last deficit but yeah you know probably
just waiting for his moment and as i say
wait for his moment he got it right
there but down four two goes to the wall
okay
oh my god what happened there we're
doing some trading places okay it goes
from that one there's a whiff punish
good break on the throw puts him in rage
now luffy with the life leaders back
into the wall though trying to get walls
back nice counter here and luffy and
take the first match and ladies like
this is still a first or two our final
first or two of the day
so you haven't got a lot of time to make
the adaptation man luffy was the one who
put him into loser bracket initially in
the winner's side now he's looking to do
it in the losers again here bubsy i
wonder what he got car hit by i'm trying
to see there's me i'm trying to do a
dissertation in my head trying to do
some theory you know so i can hand it
into uni like what did he press
before he was doing the downfall one
swayed back down forward one sway back
so i'm guessing maybe sway about sizes
so maybe try to
do something to track the side step but
i guess jim's got a hole in me which is
quite quick so i'm i'm trying to make a
calculation like how he got caught hit
because he just went sway back straight
into the three so
there were some there must have been
some mind games there i'm just trying to
yeah in that situation when you block
down forward one i think the best thing
to do is to size that right and duck i'm
i'm pretty sure right uh it beats most
of the options i'm not sure if it beats
a downfall once way back down forward
one because down forward one tracks
decision right um so there's yeah this
is definitely mind games playing out
here but we are not seeing the option
stacks that we usually see from people
in that sway scenario right because if
you had size up and duct then that would
have beaten that that low and you would
have low powered it it's easier said
than done yeah it's 100 easier than that
for sure like i'm not saying oh i should
have done it bro like no of course but
like it's it is something that you can
do versus that way
so we're going to go straight back in i
wonder if this mean a stage change
character change maybe nope definitely
not character change these guys are
loyalists to their characters we're
going to go to the island paradise one
of the newer dlc um stages i think it
was the one before last
right uh no this was the this was the uh
oh yeah yeah this is the
lydia release right
yes yeah and you can see that right now
on we've seen the the beach right we're
seeing the beach dan it's like uh i
think one of the if not the biggest uh
surface areas of any tekken stage once
you go downstairs so it's very hard to
find the walls even with the crazy wall
carry that we have nowadays with these
characters one thing i can say for sure
about this stage is it's one of the most
beautiful stages man i could do of a
beach right now i think it was a good
time to bring it out you know it's like
you know what come on i might not be
able to go to the beach but i can't at
least play on it right now break this
balcony and we'll go to the beach right
now
take us to the beach man
nice pressure here nice excited could
have got a little bit more if you've
done the three two that would have been
game
luffy yola go for it night oh nice dark
night oh oh
this is back with a rage drive of his
own that rage drive like is one of the
that hurts like i i felt that in my gut
i'm not even playing it's one of those
one that physically hurts you but lovely
parry there right staying composed gets
the parry into the can cans take it to
the wall side look at that why does he
have that move
no he needs the wall in it
that's why he needs it he needs the wall
even more now
nice demon's poor gets blocked okay
catching him ducking at the wall
oh he's got another point he's got in
the corner oh my beautiful i love the
patience there and what read the timing
that timing he's done it twice as well
he just messed with the timing stayed in
his face done a little bit of movement
back left a bit and just knew okay this
is when you're gonna buy it
yeah and that's that's a scary position
you know for rice because luffy is one
match up and two rounds up and he's able
to make a to take a few risks here and
play a bit wild
okay nice about 2-1
nice good job there with the jabs
needs to be very careful because that if
he does if he goes back into the crowd
fast free you probably all can't hear
maybe that's what you've done before
yeah i might have jabs yeah yeah maybe
maybe you've got a car hit there but
he's on the board now either way right
trying to work on this reverse sleep he
needs two rounds in a row to stay alive
here luffy you're not gonna make it easy
for him yeah as we said this is a
first two territory still so luffy is on
set point
oh we're going to the beach oh yes we
are son here we go
okay okay nice okay me there go to the
down two haven't dunked there
nice yo seven golden letters right now
one round away from the reverse sweep
has you got that that um tournament
power up where you know you're gonna
lose
yeah you need to put all your eggs in
the basket now nice dark could've got a
little could have got last time in two
there but look at this bob see the
comeback from right this could be dead
and yes it is no it's not oh my god
shout out the wall is gonna get another
perfect
did i just kiss it
nice yo
ladies and lads rife stays alive three
rounds in a row it was looking all luffy
but maybe you got a bit too comfortable
with the lead bubsy and just let it let
it slip it's just one of those things
where it's such a dangerous position to
be in like when
do you
keep going with the attack do you
step off a bit it's just one of those
things where when you start hesitating
and doubting and how you're going to
approach this match and approach this
round
that your opponent then you know can get
their stuff started so it it happens
more time than often than you think
actually
when people get to that kind of
positioning
yeah it's rough man like luffy's done
this before as well he was up one match
before he was looking really solid in
the in the uh second in the second game
and he just let it slide he let it slide
man so
man i don't know what to i don't know
what he needs to do i don't know
it's one of your poetry sayings that you
said like when someone sees the light at
the end of the tunnel and it's just too
blinding
what's happening how did you say it
again
yeah that's exactly it you see the light
at the end of the tunnel and it blinds
you right so
you just you just you just lose sight of
the finish and you just and you end up
getting too cocky you overextend a lot
and yeah just get bodied yeah he was he
was that was his um set point there he
was on that was his round but
to win to take the set but you know i'm
sure luffy you said this before he is a
veteran player he he's one of the best
pools in the world
um
there's no doubt he can he can
definitely make a comeback and like
regain that composure
sometimes it's all about composing just
regaining yourself just having that
little break you know while the match
loads up and just going back to what was
getting you the wins you know that's the
thing
is the fact that rife when he has
momentum oh it's very scary he's a
momentum based player for sure
definitely he's definitely he's
definitely composed but when he has
momentum and if he if he starts this
this round off and gets the win luffy's
gonna have a hard time to make it back
yeah we've seen race just literally run
like just
run over guys
definitely with that momentum and it
looks like you know he's in position now
but no i can't use that parry
okay
available nice block
oh gets hit by the delay there that
string is that string is one of the best
strings i think in the game just you can
delay it you can just throw it out and
it's safe
wow look at that the side step right
into duck from uh from luffy gets the
punishment right get up kick we're going
downstairs yes yeah there we go he gets
and he finds the wall still there you go
bam bam get some wall combo still got
his back wall we need to be very careful
okay trying to step out the wall i like
it i respect it it should be very my god
man this is looking all right right now
but i told you buzzy it's all about
momentum can luffy bring it back he has
rage available down four two gets
blocked okay he's pushing him towards
the wall with the rage drive okay nice
cancel knew that would be punishable
for the low man oh
the string that everyone forgot about
one down three
five rounds straight now for right five
rounds in a row he's one luffy's on the
back foot he was so close to winning
this entire set and moving at the top to
that right has him in the corner he
definitely has all the answers now he is
this is when rafe is scariest when he
has that momentum and he has you pinned
down
and no one's a beautiful oh my god great
blood
that's gonna be it six runs straight a
mini pop off there for life luffy will
be eliminated from the tournament after
being up five rounds yeah that is wow
just six round comeback yeah like we
we've seen this song like from um
from watching rafe right from the loop
watching all these matches today we've
seen that once he gets going he cannot
be stopped
so let's take a look look back at some
of these some of these instances
yes for sure man you know it was all
luffy to start off man that first match
was so so dominant and then even here
right you know you can see the momentum
was all on his side and winning this one
he had him in the corner this is what
you talked about bubsy the raw shoulder
yeah that's when you know he's in your
head and after that race bringing it
back three rounds straight and just ran
with the momentum yeah it's like i said
he's definitely from watching him play
today he is one of the scariest players
that it just seems like no one has the
answer once he gets going and he gets
that momentum and he's in your head and
he's using those parries it looks like
no one's been able no no no one has been
able to stop him you know it looks like
no one has he's just he's run it now
he's in
loser's final is he going to make that
losers run
can he make the run i mean the way he's
been you know after luffy put him into
loser bracket he's just been bodying
everyone man he's got momentum he's
definitely gonna have a lot of
confidence after beating the person who
beat him right can i get some can i get
some martial arts in the chat man that
was a very very good second i'm liking
this man it's halal
i've loved it now we have uh the top
three it's losers finals it's gonna be
sideways versus uh israel complained
versus life and i don't think we've seen
that match today either so it's gonna be
interesting
no we definitely honestly no we haven't
seen that much at all i don't think so i
don't think we saw that much no um but
again these are these are guys both guys
have a lot of momentum right now rife
running the loser back in goldman and
complain who had a very close set in the
winner's finals so on point right now
for sure both guys
definitely definitely on point so
talking about on point look at this
tekken these good ass tekken t-shirts
doesn't sound right as a british saying
good ass tekken i don't know you've got
to say good you have to try hard to say
good ass because you don't say ass we
say ass
good ass tekken yeah because some could
ask tekken but these are these shirts
are on point so make sure you get these
these are officially licensed tekken
merchants that i brought to you by tenno
you know visit the website down there
and channel
um ten dash oh sorry dot gg four slash
merch or you can just do the easiest
thing scan the qr code it takes you
right there these shirts go like
hotcakes so these are actually back in
stock you're saying these um went out
before the class this nice martial law
one
make sure you pick these up
these these look they're fly let's just
say that man these are stamped of
approval from me these look great i'm
gonna have to whisper some sweet nothing
to get a couple of these
i love the rooster colors as well with
the white and so the the black and
yellow but yeah um i feel like we should
get we need to get a steve one what do
you guys think about that one a steve
t-shirt was just good ass tekken yeah
the british one yeah so we can say it
properly because
you know it for me it just doesn't sound
right when i say oh yeah
we need a steve good ass tekken t-shirt
yeah i had an r in there
okay yeah uh definitely i don't know
about the tenno dot gg4 merch scan the
qr code officially lasts the second
merchandise brought to you by 10 0 man
it's not we haven't got a lot of um
official tekken merch out there i know
most of it was in japan with those uh jb
style t-shirts right but
you guys and us guys can now get our
hands on those t-shirts from uh sitting
from home man but also make sure to
follow uh at twitter and youtube for bne
esports and of course um tekken on
twitter twitch and facebook to keep up
to date with everything happening in the
tekken world yes definitely you don't
want to miss anything that's happening
in tekken world because these games
look at the these pristine games that
we're catching but
unfortunately we're gonna have to go for
a little short break you know get some i
need to get a little bit of refreshment
too because these matches are so hyped
so when we come back we're going to move
further for further further on into this
um
top eight bringing you i think the
losers flying all right yeah we're top
three now it's all the first retreat
from here top three so you definitely
don't want to miss this so make sure get
yourself refreshed toilet breaks
everything and come back
because
you don't want to miss this top three so
stay tuned
[Music]
wow
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
the tarnished
will soon return
guided by grace
once lost
the golden order is broken
to its core
so
foul tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
they will fight
and they will die
in an unending curse
wow is a champion or a lord
to be born
well
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
brandish the elden ring
for all of us
it's not just our power
it's all of our powers working as a team
don't underestimate me
here
[Applause]
we have to work together
[Music]
[Applause]
focus
connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the world
you two handle the front while i take it
back
don't bother resisting i will obtain the
red strings
[Music]
[Music]
pretty fancy place they got here
harmony and coexistence
between the renance and the danon's
should you need my skills on the
battlefield all i care for is
maintaining peace
i'm captain kisara of the elder men in
sea of god
from now on when i fight
i fight to protect my dream
well this crew just gets bigger and
bigger
the renin's
seems the rumors you were running with
them were true
been looking for you
get the hell out of my realm
this is tannen's realm and it's ours
understand
is it over
it's only just begun
ladies and lads welcome back to the
tekken online challenge 2021 online
master event here for the middle east
region my name is joined by bubsy and
that was just a look at some of the
titles that bandai namco institute have
been working on really really cool stuff
man i'm actually quite excited for uh
you know very excited for elden ring i'm
to play that game you're sick um you
know the other games are really sick as
well man so yeah uh hopefully some of
you guys were we're excited watching
those trailers man definitely man you
see um actually tells the variety is
actually out now
um so definitely go and pick it up we
saw scarlet um nexus and he saw those
great revolt review scores as well it
seems that bandai namco entertainment
big shout out to them i've got a great
array of games to keep everyone
entertained man so why are you not
playing
yeah and you've you've actually worked
with them as well so you know how it
goes into like the effort that goes into
making some of these games
that's just pretty sick man but ladies
and gents moms and dads family friends
and friends do not forget that astro uh
the official headset and mix of the
tekken online challenge 2021 you see
bubsy showing yeah
big shout out to them uh but yes it is
top three time now for um the technology
master if i haven't released we have
three different um regions represented
countries represented in our top three
we have georgia israel and saudi arabia
so there's a little bit for everyone to
look forward to here in this top three
publisher definitely and like i said
it's such a it's been such a diverse
tournament and it's great to see three
different representations now in top
three is what more could you ask for you
know
so we should uh let's take a look at the
leaderboard actually why not let's let's
yeah yes
because um we'll be in a better position
to understand what is going to happen
here so
uh luffy yeah he had a finish of um
fourth place which gave him a hundred
points yeah uh of course it hasn't
updated because we don't know how many
points ultra insane potatoes gonna get
but he's definitely actually in first
effectively
um bk finished with 50. so really uh
well and truly um complain and
um
and and uh
could get 300 points if they win but
ultra into potato has guaranteed 220
which means he will uh guaranteed be
first place at the end of the tournament
yeah
great great results for him trying to
actually just do some maths myself um
so one of the complain and rape they're
basically gonna end up third and second
right
the third and fourth yeah because it's
150 that's 100 points right for third
level right it's 100 points for for
first sorry for fourth right so third
we'll get 150 maybe yeah so yeah
either way everyone's sitting pretty in
this rank and whoever's in the top three
sitting pretty in these stand-ins um i
believe what i believe first is
definitely taken and now uh this match
decides who's gonna be second in the in
the in the standings so it's so much to
play for like i said you know europe and
america and and like east asia they've
had a lot of dojo events you know icfc
has been the real the real goal too when
it comes to dojo events in those regions
and they've been able to collect quite a
few points right i think your top four
dojo event points count towards your
final score so there's some people that
have been able to get even 400 points
just from just from dojos right but um
this region hasn't had that opportunity
so this master event really is so
important to decide who is going to be
in the top eight standings uh for the
middle east region and so uh complaint
and rife right now are battling for that
second place yes definitely that that
220 points
will be obviously a lot sweeter than the
than the you know z150 so
definitely want to make a big standing
on a big mark on the leaderboard um
oh james potato obviously he's sitting
in the winner's family looking really
pretty
pretty good i remember like you know
rife like
he look at the run he's hiding
it's amazing didn't he did we watch him
in the um
he had we watched him in the pre-matches
didn't in the the starter matches right
as well so he's literally yeah just
being
his momentum man it genuinely looks like
once he gets started
he cannot be stopped he hasn't been
stopped so
is complain going to be the answer
like yeah is it like you know a you know
a a 2-0 versus hunch
from uh jordan i believe uh to get that
uh to get into top eight and then you
know bk two oh devil rocky two oh yeah
luffy two one and that comeback with
luffy was six round straight it was
basically straight basically a two-o
you know six-round straight man and now
he's playing against complaining he has
so much momentum and confidence on his
side he beat the person and put him into
losers in the first place yes so can he
beat complain now it's a first to three
bubsy yeah so it's got this that's gonna
be hard so early um
my plane definitely has a little bit
more uh wiggle room now to try and stop
that momentum i probably
can you know
make a couple adjustments and see
what um
what you can do basically and
yeah it's going to be very interesting
i'm just trying to think it's going to
be yoshi jin match up here and 100 i
guess one of the scariest things that
i guess yoshi has the evasion but the
spin but jin standing four is is it the
fastest hormone move in the game
uh
it's definitely gonna be one of them but
you have poor with the back two right
back one is four frames i mean
so yeah we have some pretty quick chroma
moves in this game but ladies and gents
here we go top three action first of
three let me hear it in the chat man who
do you guys think is gonna take this man
you guys are two you're talking too slow
man i'm not seeing the chat move fast
enough let's go ladies at saudi versus
israel
all right so down four two now gonna
catch him and this is what what
complaint's been doing really well he's
his timing has been impeccable his
okuzami as you can see there catching
him back rolling and that is going to be
a chuckle do not tech versus yoshimitsu
complain with the first round
this is what you want to see if you're
complaining man you know not an oh my
god the sidewalk right so after ford for
unblock if you sidewalk right it beats
most if not all of jin's options right
from the you can see him doing it again
so early on we're seeing complain really
know what to do versus the gin matchup
the question is that rife if he can get
just one round a couple of rounds
together that's all he needs because
he's a very momentum based player
okay so now here we go that has a big
whiff there could have got a launch
i just fought for just using the the
boots
oh that's the float but just like finish
it with down four then we go right
gonna bring it back one round a piece is
this the start of the momentum is this
the start of the rafe train i thought i
have to call it another race train just
a rave train
oh talking about that big car here this
is definitely gonna go to the wall
hey i wonder why he opts to go for that
and not the um new laser scraper
yeah i wonder yeah i mean
i guess he just prefers the uh the other
other um kind of
yeah yeah he doesn't
this guy definitely actually probably do
it again oh he could have done it again
but now that's the mix up and then uses
the rage drive one of the better race
drivers in the game like i said it has a
couple
high um crushing probability yeah and
you see once again man this is something
wright's going to have to adapt to
because every time complaint blocks the
forward four into zen he is side walking
right and shutting down the options yes
he said it definitely is one of those
things where it evades most of the
options um you see that yeah he's using
the homie move he had to kind of stop
that
yeah nice down four two
there we go no sword combo what is that
combo oh my god he doesn't get the last
hit at the tail spin
he's gonna go for the ah nice punish i
reckon if he was just a little bit
slower than that punish a flashlight
with a calm
oh my god nobody got the pickup nah that
combo is quite tricky to do
just catches him ducking at the end now
that right there why he ducks he's
probably thought the rage drive was
coming now the first hit of jin's race
drive is high and can be done
he made such a big read then got um
launched for that it's actually lost him
around that hard read
there
do it again why not
oh there we go big launch
i
guess
this is dangerous now because you're
going to be at the wall and you know how
good yoshi meets his oh he's on the wall
he flips him over again he knows he's
going to stay down yes again so that's
that's the mix-up we said before this
could potentially be if you guess the
right ball no i don't think so come on
one more he's gonna do it hello harry
complain he sucks that out he knew he
was coming right has gone for that every
single time complete on point that shows
that he's been watching he's probably
been watching the matches he probably
got the stream on and has seen that one
down three the forgotten move the
forbidden move i have generally said it
before i forgot jin had that the jabbing
to low and right they scouted it out
said you've done this one too many times
and i've been watching i've been paying
attention i've been doing my homework i
handed in the essay i've done it
like you know yeah no no he definitely
says that man he's been watching he was
in the winner's side so he had a lot of
a lot of opportunity to watch um rife
play in the loser side right when you're
in winners you get more time to kind of
watch the losers lose a bracket action
um and yeah he definitely that was
coming stay composed complain um
had no business winning that round
really it's just great great um
composure once again he's been in
tournaments he's a he's a veteran let's
see if rafe can bring it back he just
needs momentum
he was it showed that um complaint is
not sleeping at the will he's definitely
still on alert still there
watching the game and being able to make
this because that little paris it was
clutch because
it would he would have lost right and
it's just clutch that he managed to make
it at that kind of time when the
pressure was on
you know and take that one game
advantage now which is huge now he's
he's a step closer into making it into
that grand finals into getting those
points to get onto that leaderboard
so okay he's opted to go for the
infinite azure wall of stage he wanted
to go now he wants to go for pure tekken
the purest form you know filtered water
just pure
nothing
yeah and i think this is a great
decision as you can see the infinite
azure the infinite stage because i mean
those those wall scenarios really mess
rape up and i think that um the wall
damage that jim's gonna get is it's not
worth it you know compared to the kind
of stuff that yoshi makes me do to you
okay off to go for the hot kick no
respect it doesn't get a proper tail
spin and just runs in easter can't hit
launch was a bit too
antsy there
oh nice set up there gets a tech roll
and just uses the power club complain
now australian racer i can run the
momentum train too can you stop this
yeah we talked about uh wright having a
lot of momentum but what about complain
you know he's someone also that's been
drinking very well the life parry is
gonna get a full can cans it's so
amazing that he knows the exact um
options to use after he parries like
it's not to think about it on the fly
and do it like that it's not an easy
thing to do
yeah now i've had the pleasure of
playing against eye musician in
tournament in korea on an infinite
station i'm telling you uh one piece of
advice i was given i was probably i did
very well first for my first time
because everyone loses him the first
time the one thing that you have to do
versus yoshi um on an infinite stage is
try to stay mid range that's what loja
said because he said that if you stay
mid-range then yoshimitsu won't be able
to just go back to the start would start
and you know recovering their health
yeah okay so you have to you can't back
that's too much if you're too patient
because you business can start to annoy
you
yeah definitely
yeah i can definitely see that as just
makes you being an annoying character
double can't hit there no one can really
capitalize after that
nice spin out don't get old uses the
parry but
fortunately for him oh great pick up
that's nice instant while standing paul
okay i see you race oh why you ducking
oh my god he didn't want to get sent to
johanna but it's okay he gets the match
anyway there we go life his success
ratio for making these guys dark i'm
really impressed like he's been hitting
so many guys with the axe kick and
i guess the threat of the
the hell sweep um into launch is
he he just says up so well like so many
of these guys are ducking in that
situation
yeah but you know what it is it's like
he's definitely scouting him this is
what you're supposed to do but imagine
when you're on offline tournaments when
you're in offline tournaments you you
you watch your opponents you know
they're playing you know that they're
going to be coming up next you say okay
let me see how he plays and you're
watching he says this is a tendency this
is what everyone does right so he's been
doing this and yes he's been using a lot
of the hell street he's been using a lot
of it so maybe then he was like you know
what i'm gonna duck because i know he
likes to use healthy well no he's mixing
up very well just like you said
definitely definitely um i said the
success ratio is is amazing there like
and it's kind of he's wondering a lot of
these um realms in it and it's a thing
that in that kind of sense scenario and
that's this situation
it also shows that you're in his head
like you're
two steps ahead you're a step ahead of
him just like you know
i'm in your head bro i know what you
wanna do i know you're gonna duck you
think this this health sweep is coming
boom back of the head axe kick what
you're saying round loss let's go 1-1
yeah absolutely so what is he going to
do now uh go back to the wall stage
maybe pick a small a small wall stage
here
to um to assert the the the okizami uh
potential again or is he gonna just go
straight to pull i mean his first
reaction so is one one he loses finals
the winner of this goes up against ultra
instinct potato in the grand finals so
much to play for because the winner of
this ladies actually missed it is going
to be placing second he will be in
second place for the um online challenge
leaderboard and forget about walls bro
we have flaws in stage in the stage now
as well we've got three of them
no need for an elevator there's no need
for elevator hey you're just you're
breaking through them
yes yes and we've managed to get the the
world record we're proclaiming the world
record for the quickest break of three
floors
18.67 seconds let's just get it
unofficial before someone gets really
upset it's unofficial
unofficial
just like you said he knows when to use
can cans oh he uses that flash show
showing that you know
okay nice so that is that's even scarier
so you can't really stay on the ground
can you
did he just um
did he just do what i think he did on us
on a sword
wow
pretty cool
she's a cool character
yeah i mean i don't i don't realize
you've got a tail
does that tend to pull the tail it is
right
wait is it isn't it
oh god this is going to be big damage
we're going to go down no okay
keep it oh wait for the downstream minus
14.
think it may break the floor is gonna
get standing for telstra okay no while
standing free
not gonna hit such a great conversion
then no this is what this is what we're
talking about character specialist
knowing how to optimize get the maximum
damage there yeah
fight and that's it man he he threw him
out of the power crusher he wasn't able
to break it
nice goes for the um
the the saw suit this time doesn't get
parried that's actually deja vu that
same sequence happened in the last game
but he's going for the paris actually
get and got hit by the sword sweet
i can't can't duck but no launch where
was the combo i don't know
everybody gets a second attempt at a
combo right now
yoshi isn't raised needs to be careful
does have access uh oh
okay i said it you gotta be careful
punish oh no
that is not something that you can do
versus yoshimitsu definitely so for
people that do not know spring kicks can
be launched punished by yoshimichi but
the flash is something that you do not
really want to use against him
yeah oh no miss times is okie and leaves
himself open to get sword swept complain
now back in
okay i was a bit out of range for that
hot kick
okay i guess the punish nice side i'm
gonna watch that wow
no oh you're going to go to the lecture
okay i like this
they're being very patient now uses the
rage drive
okay now i like this race just slowing
it down a bit trying to just regain some
position and need to be very careful
because his back is kind of against the
wall we're both
nice patience there and a one two three
i think he tried to flash in between
that it looked like yeah he got hit
though so it was not not not an option
there from complain now here we go okay
use that one for a forward four using
them boots these boots are made for
walking no they're not they make the
kicking
yes brave now he's he's being a lot more
patient in this in these last couple of
rounds
yeah
i mean okay this gets caught with the
downfall too
okay
all right oh big big weird could have
got a can can or something there
yeah nice spins out
yep
good punish right there oh be careful be
careful yoshi with rage need to be very
very careful and just use his opposites
to go for the jab there quick and smooth
nice and clean
yeah keeps him in check there and
rafe taking that that was um
it was scary at first because he's using
the spring kicks i was thinking is he
flustered because he's seen that um
complain is ready with the punish so i
didn't want him i was thinking is he an
autopilot now is he kind of checked out
a bit but not came back regained that
composure
and he's now he's taking the next game
so yeah absolutely this is looking good
here for reif now but the thing is uh
last time
uh the last time complaint was in
position he picked paul
right so i i don't think that that's the
same situation as it was versus
alternating but i think that going to a
wall stage no floor breaks uh he could
definitely win with the yoshimitsu but
uh i think
now that rafe has checked you've seen
that he's changed his timing yeah he's
chained up he's being a lot more patient
and that is definitely definitely put um
complaint off because complaint has been
thriving on people being aggressive as
him if you're aggressive versus yoshi he
has so many options he's got the flash
he has down four two the downfall twos
of yoshi from campaign have been so on
point right so now ray's deciding you
know what i'm gonna play a little bit
more patient two rounds in a row and
managed to take the match but what did
he do now maybe that he's being more
patient he decides to go to paul because
maliki who is one of the best players in
europe
he also has two characters ask her and
paul and he said to me that like we said
to us actually that he would play asaka
when people are quite aggressive but
when they start to be really patient he
picks paul because paul is a character
that can open you up a lot easier right
he has moves that can just body you
right very very quickly so is that what
it complains thinking now is he thinking
now that he's playing more patient do i
go to paul that is a good question um
but this is this is like last chance
saloon right it's 2-1
so yeah he's going to be locked and
loaded with this so he needs to really
carefully think about it
wow bang
his old mane in tekken tag two
yoshimitsu and feng was his main team i
remember playing him on three bars back
in the day in ranked and yes feng is so
much more we're actually saying this
before the streamboxes that campaign has
and in season four that character is so
much stronger he is definitely an
underrated character but it doesn't
matter how underrated you are you're
getting count hit by that and wall
stretch
it doesn't matter how highly raised you
are
oh my god that hurt me
what a conversion doesn't get the wall
though but complainers in a very bad
position and needs to get this thing
started up geez oh no oh no this is bad
for complaining right man you don't let
him get don't let him get momentum
to sleep oh no he's trying to send him
to hell he's definitely got the momentum
right now
oh is this going to be another putt no
it's not perfect
nice okay he uses that survey but he's
just rafe is just disrespecting just
going for jabs all the time after his
frames
[Music]
and again completely oh my god he's
getting flustered he's attacking me not
supposed to be attacking him doing a
very good job keeping that frame tight
there getting those car hit launchers
i'm not gonna say that again guess
another one he's like you think you
could pick feng versus me like no bro
what are you doing look at this from
rafe right now
with all the momentum looking super
super easy oh my gosh that was the wrong
combo oh this could be the start of
something but gets the sidewalls flat
okay try to catch some duck in there
oh the classic i knew it was coming the
while standing two into the savaki
said you've got two shoes i'm going to
step on both of them
get the mustang
okay go to the downfall complain now is
this the moment that he needs is this
that the round that he needed to catch
that momentum to try and stop rafa have
you got a big car hit
yep
nice block good block plus frames
oh gosh we've got 10 hits
i always get nervous when i start seeing
10 hits
oh man he threaded the needle with that
one he gets a side wall splat nice
conversion
rave
very close to making it into grand
finals here for the master event
spends that rage drive
i mean that rage that's so good as a get
off me tall but he has to make this
comeback clean
oy
he just looks unstoppable
it is it was going to stop him
i don't know man because the only person
that can stop him now is ultra insane
potato because he is going to move
into the grand finals here eliminating
complaint from the tournament a great
showing by complaining uh from israel uh
really really good showing but um yes
from saudi arabia will move into grand
finals had to go up against ultra
instinct potato hey was the replay first
with reaction and yeah i mean i guess in
hindsight the uh the the fan pick wasn't
the best but lovely low power i mean
it's straight from the start though you
saw bob did that right on it definitely
they said that that was a clutch one
right there but then it just seemed that
rafe just picked up the momentum as he
saw there just was in his head rent-free
said i know you're gonna duck
so i've got this kick for you and this
is such a pivotal round here 2-1 would
have been big uses a spin
the one down three there and you know
just honest with the jabs
and then yeah for sure man and then you
know going to his old main head with
feng from tekken tag two and you know i
know you can see that he he plays his
character but rafe looked so comfortable
he used the upward too so much i wonder
if he had some knowledge about feng in
that situation using that side step move
uh but
finally both the characters actually
have the same move in that scenario
right they have a little sidestep punch
um but definitely rife looked like very
comfortable in that thing matchup maybe
he plays against that character quite
often but either way ladies and gents
it's gonna be saudi arabia
versus georgia for our grand finals here
for the middle east there are five saudi
arabians in the in the top eight and one
of them has managed to make it into the
grand finals yes
and of course guys uh this was the
middle east you're watching right now um
for the master event but there's so much
more yet to come you can see it here
guys south asia south east asia
philippines decision uh
oceana korea and japan you guys are not
familiar with oceana's that's like kind
of the australian region um which we
don't get to see a lot of but have very
strong players and of course southeast
south east asia something i'm really
looking forward to because those
countries have killers that we have some
of them guys came down to europe one
time and beat people like tishman and
asked him and these guys like like very
strong players there so i'm excited to
see talent from from those regions and
of course in the regional finals i
listed on the right side uh so please
put these down on your calendars you
definitely do not want to miss these 100
do not want to miss this i'm talking
about don't want to miss anything you do
not want to miss these t-shirts we've
said this all stream i've said it before
these t-shirts are looking badass i
can't say ask properly
as you see you've got the good ass
tekken king if you want these t-shirts
do the easy ones scan the qr code you
can visit 10 dash o dot gg forward slash
merc these are officially last tekken
merchandise brought to you by tenno
media so big shout outs to those guys
and you can see they've got the lord
design is that what's that called what's
that man called the the legend legend
kick that's the one right there
you know and of course if you actually
go on to the um
if you if you actually go onto the tenno
gg website you'll see that most of the
t-shirts are actually sold out so these
ones were back in stock because they
were very popular um and they come in
different colors now so yeah you
definitely want to get your hot your
hands on these because it's official
official tekken t-shirts and there's not
uh there haven't been uh historically a
lot of this kind of merchandise
available so uh once they're gone
they're gone guys so get your hands on
them scan the qr code go to the website
whatever you want to do but later lads
here is the tailor this is how it all
went down um started off with five
saudis in the top eight and complain um
one jordanian and of course the
israelian complaint uh and
just looked it was a really really uh
close
close matches with the in the win of
winners finals 2-3 going to uh alternate
i think but then rife you can see it man
look at the results this man has had
like even before so he won two o versus
hunch going to top eight two of us is bk
two o versus double rocky two one versus
luffy and then three one versus
complaint this man has a momentum here
yes he is a man definitely on the
mission you got that lower bracket
losers bracket gulag whatever you want
to say
power up and now he's made it all the
way
to the grand finals and we said we said
it before he
he's just i personally think he's just
looking unstoppable in a minute like
once he gets going
he's he's going he's gone you know see
you later i'm gone but you know this is
the last chance can ultra this is the
last person i can stop him can't ultra
instinct stop it and you said this
before and i hate to say this
because i don't want to put any curses
on people we said we've seen it so many
times
where someone from
losers ends up winning and taking that
and yeah the thing is right
he's got if he does he's got so much
time is it you know it's going to be he
has to win two sets
and if he gets that momentum and that
big momentum
it's gonna be a very hard hard um
hard to stop him and i i don't know yeah
yeah yeah the thing is like we said it
before right that
saudi arabia has a lot of experience
versus the king matchup right and you
saw with the rifle versus feng verses
versus like different characters that he
just looked super comfortable he when he
like he definitely has studied multiple
match-ups right uh king is a very
popular character in
uh in saudi so
can he deal with the style of king
that's the question the style of king
that ultra intimate will bring because
it's a very different style to the ones
that you have in saudi arabia so
i'm excited for this saudi versus
georgia match up um and of course rife
like you said so momentum based if you
can get a couple of matches early on he
could definitely take the whole time oh
yeah i i wouldn't be surprised if
we see a bracket reset and we see rafe
go on and making it ultra close but um
but at least ultra instinct
he has that buffer let's talk about him
he has that buffer he's in the winner's
side
so he can kind of use a game or two just
to kind of maybe get some information
like he can do that extended
period where it's not just like trying
to get straight away because he has that
leeway now
can see maybe come up with a plan to try
and slow him down because we saw before
where um
rafe did play
and complain kind of made him slow down
just for that little bit in that moment
where he had like maybe a slight
hesitation when campaign was coming
getting those rounds and getting them
getting the set one set and like he kind
of changed his gameplay and slowed him
down
so it's it's it's it's gonna be like can
ultra instinct
recreate that make um rape doubt himself
make him when he's trying to go for the
max kicks like you know not duck and
then go for the the hell sweep and then
maybe block those health sleeves because
he you've seen he's he's very good with
those mix-ups
yeah yeah for sure man yeah i mean i
think that we're not going to see any
the other thing is that we're not going
to see any different characters
i think it's going to be jin and king
the whole way
and that's the exciting thing because
we're going to have to see adaptation
over everything else right yeah
i haven't really seen riff play any
other character today and in general uh
okay you know what let me just shut up
and not talk and not say anything let me
just let me just let me just go and i
want to leave guys
he's out of the building
i mean
he said that before he does have a
little buffer and it could be a thing
where he's seen he maybe watched um
ultra instant potato maybe have watched
a match between rafe and um devil rocky
which was played earlier on and he he
beat um devil rocky 2-zip
and and it was against the king so maybe
this is
you've seen something i don't know all
right here we go ladies and gents the
grand finals here saudi arabia vs
georgia and you know it's it's if if he
was gonna try a different character now
now is the right time where you have a
cushion of being in the winner's side of
the grand finals right but talking about
cushion and it seems like and um
nina needs a cushion because she's
getting beaten up on
and yeah down four okay and you know do
you know why i don't agree with this
like okay maybe you feel like uh this is
a better matchup for you but the risk
he's taking giving rafe any bit of
momentum is a very scary thing to do
well it really looks like he's he's
starting like he means business
oh no
yeah was is this gonna come back to bite
him in the booty
bite him in the booty oh gosh
he's just okay nice he's got to stop
doing that bro
he's going to get to the wall of course
he's going to get to oh that is a very
nice conversion i'm not sure about the
wall combo after and wow kind of
amounted to nothing there so ray already
on the train
he's he's looking unstoppable but like
he said this isn't all james's um main
character he's probably maybe using this
as
a tester but it
may not be a good idea mate look at this
domination right now from a rape he's
just rushing him down bulldogging not
letting him get anything started he's in
the corner right now so this is an
opportunity for ultra interpreter he has
rage available as well but rafe
can't hit trade
okay nice uses the rage
no great
what's that okay here that was the worst
we need to be very careful and up
forward too we've seen this so much
we've seen him
put this move out and be very successful
with it it does have evasive um
properties a little side step there and
that looks comfortable um all right
ladies and lads uh the grandparents
hasn't started yet it's gonna start now
okay so we're hoping we're guessing that
we're going to get a king pick from
ultra superhero because that didn't work
but again um if he had an idea of maybe
this could work versus gin because he
again both complain and
potato have had a bit a long opportunity
to watch grace play in losers so they're
trying to scout him out whichever way
possible
he's tried after nina he's in winner's
side of the grandfather which means
ladies and gents that rife has to win
two first or threes and uh a potato only
needs to win one so for him you know
this is a if he wants to try out a new
character now was his only chance really
you don't want to mess around now don't
stand back don't try anything new go
with what's been working if it ain't
broke don't fix it and see if you can
take this guy out yeah um this is scary
because now he's already given him that
momentum he's got him started and
these characters like gin is not
conventional down for two inputs it's
you know you have to warm up their
fingers or stick with the wrists and
he's warm
this guy's ready for the next battle as
the game just said he is ready
um i'm thinking he's going to be king i
i if i see a nina on the screen again
it's
going to be yeah it had to be king you
have to go back hopefully he used that
one game
to
download whatever information he needed
to download um yeah i mean i don't i
don't think that there was any
downloading going on i was trying to be
nice but yeah yeah
it was such a professional it was just a
beat down let's be honest and no
information was was was gathered now
we're going to start with our grand
finals but it's 1-0 right now
in this first set first to three ladies
and gentlemen going to the brimstone of
fire let's go okay nice okay this is
what i was talking about getting those
when i'm getting those blocks on the
health sleep really you know making him
doubt when to use them like he gets the
wall bounce
yeah
and that's one of those strings as well
man like it's it's got a high option in
the middle right so yeah probably tried
to duck that and oh my god oh he wanted
to end it now but gets the whiff
punished with the back one two and
already he's looking
very much so
comfortable now a lot more comfortable
okay
nice so that rave is not asleep at the
will at all he's ready for the punish
there we go against the big boy combo
he opted to i think one reason why he
might be going for down back to string
instead is because he if if you don't go
for the flip flop it allows them to tech
roll and potentially get themselves out
of the wall right so maybe he just likes
to keep him at the wall there oh yeah
definitely keeping someone at the wall
with that pressure um the way he's
playing
is is optimal man
are we gonna go to the wall bam bam what
a combo bro what the hell brave lovely
lovely stuff like this guys and he knows
like the degrees and curves of these
walls what the hell man got his protag
protractor out here
shout out to
i haven't bought anything from there
since
after secondary school bro i'm surprised
that's that shop's still around you know
like it's been ages
well i guess you know i've got people
going to school all the time now but
talking about going to school he's going
to take him to the wall
too cool for school
oh boy oh boy oh man oh the combat video
i'm not punished
punish
oh my gosh and that just shows that in
that ultra instant potatoes probably
rocked and just
just fell asleep at the wheel there
yeah there we go we're gonna get to the
wall uh big boy combo that only wants
some bigs on i'm sure i just wakes up
giant swing but rave is ready he's got
the momentum
yeah definitely he's in the zone right
now man talking about ultra instinct i
mean right now right if it's in ultra
instinct the heavy guy can you get
something started nice throughout that
was really nice converters gonna get no
he doesn't get the guarantee the
template what oh kazemi right there now
this could potentially be it
people's lives let's go for the throw
mix up okay alley kick
blaze oh gosh
okay what's the mix up now and
beautiful there clutching it out using
the rage drive for the plush frames and
finishing it with the low this wow guy
is
i i don't know
he's he's playing out of his mind right
now he's
he's found another level he's on another
level in a minute like yeah i cannot see
how he can be stopped it just seems like
no one can stop him at this minute it
just seems like everything's aligned for
him the stars the moon everything it's
just it's there for him man
yeah my man did a wudu before he started
well he washed his hands his face
everything man he's ready he did his
door before the tournament bro this guy
is he's he's asking for a lot to save
him here man and get him that reset
grand finals can he do it i mean look uh
that first ma i said that you know it's
fine to try a new character but
against rife when you see the way he's
playing
it's just like you don't want to give
this man any momentum if that was the
first match
then it's fine the second match you can
try and make it make a comeback but now
is it too little too late obviously is
it too late i really hope not and now
that he's saying that i know this is
just me speaking in hindsight maybe it
would be best for him to start with king
and then if it went to the bracket reset
then try a new character on that one
as you you tried your main and it hasn't
worked so maybe try to switch it up then
but
i'm not in the driver's seat i don't
know this is why i'm here so
so is he gonna go to the uh to the
forgotten realm now are we going to get
some opportunities for big boy damage
with the kings we actually haven't seen
it much from we haven't from uh potato
no he's going to choose to go for the
howard estate inspector
yeah yeah yeah both eastern can net some
pretty big damage for king um but
he now needs to think about you know um
the next the next first of three i know
you shouldn't be thinking about giving
up just use this time now to just play
and try to download as much information
as possible it is 2-0 um
rife only needs one more match to reset
the bracket but i mean if anyone can get
can can make this come back it is ultra
inspiratory as we say to start us off
with the healthy he is definitely
okay no it gets punished there
again oh my gosh dude he's
he's in old drinks to potato head this
is gonna be seven golden letters
what a statement you wanna see what you
wanna see what momentum looks like
ladies now this is the perfect example
the man is in the zone he ran a massive
gauntlet in the loser's side after
losing to luffy he managed to make his
comeback against luffy got the run back
beat complain moved to grand finals and
he is so close to resetting this bracket
he's all over australian recipe it's
like you know
he's not getting a chance to get
anything slightly even blocked loaded
and even get like a punishment okay nice
get something started now
yeah
i'm done okay guess correctly not big
damage damage
okay
nice
what um
[Laughter]
this is a little bit of a tank
i'm a bit even an ultra instinct
oh nice
nice
again australian potatoes the eaters
went also
and all of a sudden it's two to one up
he just got out of the uh the hyperbolic
time chamber he just got training he
did some homework and here we go now
ultra interpolated with the momentum
nice that was a quick turnaround that's
another world record an unofficial world
record there has broken the quickest
turnaround ever
nice all right
gonna break it yes
oh my god [ __ ] combo huge damage
yes nice
and just like that
like in in the blink of an eye i should
say because we blinked our eyes and
you just free one up
[Music]
i feel like i feel like we just went to
an alternate universe that was messed up
i was tripping bro i was like what's
going on like when we just went to an
alternate universe all of a sudden it's
like oh we're commentating imagine it
like the momentum all of a sudden just
switch to switch
potato sudden he's like grabbing him
he's
potato has the momentum and managed to
claw it back so the comeback is on bubsy
um yeah those last couple of rounds
looks very dominant so like i said if
anyone can do it it is ultra insanity he
needs to compose himself and realize
that he has a cushion still you know he
has a whole a whole first of three left
to go if this one doesn't go well so
just try to um gather as much
information as possible on your opponent
on his timing and see what you can do
definitely definitely um
he's definitely slowed down ray for the
like i said late rafe is a definitely a
very momentum blaze bass player and um
yeah so breaking the momentum is what he
is what he needs to do
yeah he's got the first game
his first game sorry and yeah hopefully
that kind of slows him down and gives a
multitude to potato a little bit more
confidence in what he's gonna do
what he needs to do
what changes and adjustments he needs to
make and as he said he's got a little
bit of a cushion also so he needs to be
using this to download but
what you don't want to do is put all
your cards on the table because if he
does this puts all these cards on the
table it doesn't like work in his favor
it could be another wraith
momentum based train and
i don't know it's hard to stop him it's
been very good that's what i'm talking
about man but here we go let's get back
into it so uh a bit of breaking the
momentum there from rife but he's in the
loser side still one match away only one
match is needed to take to a fresh first
of three and he has started a really
strong hip obviously yes definitely
okay fourth floor
trying to net a big car hit that nice
duck use it to 24 for a punish
yeah okay
but again he's just rapist is not
letting up just pure relentless pit bull
in there
yeah he's making all the right reads as
well using that sidestep punch uh every
time he knows potato is going to try and
challenge him hop knee right to the jaw
some people sometimes just have to do it
sometimes you have to just put it out
there you know just make them have
something to think about oh that's going
to be a punishment oh that is so
unfortunate for potato a massive risk
taken
big boy combo there gets the demon port
as well
to the flip over
and you see what i mean when you go for
the flip of aoki sometimes your bat your
own back can be put to the wall oh
that's an oreo oh that's guaranteed
ultra instinct potato just skipping over
taking some of that momentum back from
rafe
you know okay nice gets the punish
should have a little parried that though
but uh-oh
is he gonna attack
he does so he mitigates the damage there
and one thing you told me a trick
quite a few years ago bobby was just
match one and three like one three one
two one three and then
you just mash him it's so easy that's my
attic
people there yeah it's a bubsy attack
man i'll be i i always take giant
spinning up into that
yeah trust me i you know what when that
happens to me i literally like take both
fingers off the stick and just do one
three one three one three one
never yeah that's literally it yeah yeah
nice
okay go through that low but just
disrespecting the frames and then ultra
instant try to disrespect his frames
i've got caught counter here
oh no it's a reset point now for saudi
arabia rafe here one more round needed
to reset the bracket ultra into potato
guess counter hit yes i can't hit four
so good with gin go straight into tail
spin
oh my god he's just running
okay but now nice readjustment there
could it let it rip
yep
ford four
okay now just back up low range
available for ultra insane potato as
well his back is to the wall down back
four rage available now what's he gonna
do race can you reset the bracket one
more he's gonna do it lasers and lads we
have a reset grand finals here
for the tekken online challenge middle
east master event it is saudi versus
georgia and we're going to a final first
to three yola
he's just got the momentum now that's
scary it's it's now i will equal scary
hours now for ultra potato because
it it just looks like even though he
made a little dent into a rafe it's just
like he just takes it straight back it's
like this guy's unfazed like it's just
like
you do what you want to do but i've got
the answer it's like he just bulldozes
his way his momentum back on top of
yours and just puts you back at square
one it is really scary
i i i genuinely do not know how to stop
this guy it just looks like he has all
the answers and it's
hard when he has that momentum
yeah a hundred percent man look we
didn't see the match that he lost to
luffy uh that that put him into the
loser bracket but for of all the matches
that we have seen this man has been
dominant dominant dominant i mean the
only match you could say was against
luffy you know in the loser bracket we
saw that match in top a and it was
he needed to make a six round comeback
but he made it he made
six rounds in a row come back against
someone like luffy that's not easy to do
and you can tell that when he has
momentum when he has confidence he just
believes in his reads and they all work
out yeah definitely so right now if
you're all trying to potentially what
are you thinking what are you doing if
you're him
i just need to really stop his momentum
and i'm thinking king's not really like
he has pokes but i want to see him as
like a key part just kind of slow down
character i guess he has the down ones
i'm down forward one he has a down one
two i guess but
they're not reliable options to you know
keep
to rely on
and eventually you know
they can get scared out a lot i i just
guess he's got to try and just
maybe offense is the best defense
sometimes but then again i wouldn't
really call class king as a really
offensive character to oppress someone
yeah
i mean you can see that rafe has been
you know doing a really good job in
keeping him out using the jab and then
going in with like a hunting sleep
sending him straight to hell and look at
this he's in the corner now okay ready
like it's bad position
and you can't get too predictable with
those giant things right there because
race did duck but didn't get a big
punish on the doubt
oh no bought him biotin it just seems
like
ultra insane potato is really
uncomfortable now because he's getting
pressing buttons where he shouldn't be
pressing buttons and
you know and just like this that was a
great example there he had a little bit
of momentum racing nope down one
no more millennium
exactly he's making he's making all the
right reads here to kind of stop
momentum look at that once again the
sidestep punch nine a break on the giant
swing so right now he is he's in the
zone bobby he's definitely zoning right
now chilling socks off and everything
how is he going to break
raped i do not know what to do what can
he do as a king player
he's trying everything he's going for
the plus range he's going for the throws
he's going for the pokes and nothing's
working right now these saudi arabians
definitely know how to play against king
ladies and gents one round away from
taking the lead in this set for the
first time life from saudi arabia okay
but gets the cow here ultra potatoes not
out of it just yet he's gonna get the
wall okay just shy of the wall
and again just has the answers just to
stop
ulting into potato four you're gonna try
and step away from the wall but it just
didn't work
just knew that you know that move with
king you can float it if you jab
absolutely oh gosh nice one in two again
what's the combo nice block i think that
may be launched i'm not sure
because the punishment anyway
three rounds straight no round brown
rafe versus audrey now if you're all
drinking potato you are panicking heart
palpitations everything anxiety loses
lots of vision you know lots of smell
taste everything
hallucinations man he's seeing armor
king now he's like what the hell is
going on this is not why i picked epic
king man like it's looking it's looking
a bit deep right now for options for
tail the momentum that rafe has if you
guys didn't know this man before this
before today now you know remember the
name but bob's it's not over yet we've
seen this many times we've seen this
many times that even with a lot of
momentum even after winning the first
match in the reset we have seen
composure we've seen tenacity and we've
seen comebacks man yeah this is um
i said it earlier on scary hours man
this is um a scary time for ultra
instant potato because
we've seen all tournament that brave
cannot be stopped and it and it seems
like history is repeating himself and
we've said before that so many people
have come back from the losers to win
and you know once i had that momentum
and it just seems like rafe with that
momentum
and it seems like he's growing as a set
grows and he's having more time and it's
just it seems like he's just i don't i
don't i don't get it he just seems like
he has the answers so ultra is a potato
for you're going to step at this wall
i'm going to use ford 4 and he's like no
i'm going to use jabs now jabs float the
homie move for king it's it's a bit of a
double-edged homie it's a good homing
move but it can be flowing and it just
seems like he's just always
like two steps ahead of the game that's
what it seems like
so yeah use it yourself right after he
got hit by the jabs and then ultra into
potato thought i have some momentum let
me carry this on he got hit by the dick
jam and it's like man every time he
tries to get something started it just
does not work but once again ultron's
been not going for a character switch
he's sticking with the king hair
straightener so i agree i think you
should do you've gone to the howard
estate now um as you can see the the
multiple uh wall breaks for some
potential big damage but
here we go he's got to get there to get
them the more breaks in the first place
such an important match here because we
do not want to see uh potato go down 2-0
that might be a little bit too much for
him super important let's see if potato
can bring it back yeah as you see he's
starting off with a lot of jabs but as i
say that just gets count here and this
is gonna go to the wall
nice realignment there go to the wall
combo
yep
again just using that toe and toe get up
just to
breathe it seems like he just wanted to
get away
oh my get kind of hit by it again he
doesn't get the combo unfortunately
punished nice again oh my god
i would arrange there bro i fully would
arrange it in that situation but either
way potato guessed around but i like
that from ultra instant potatoes so he
went for the ford four again at the wall
knowing that in the match previous that
lost in the match we got float with the
jab so it shows he's not deterred he's
he's still got his head on
yeah
okay oh my gosh okay nice conversion but
again backed against the wall okay nice
we're gonna get some big damage here
okay breaks it
yep one push to your throat take it to
the oh no he doesn't even go for a tail
spin yeah he should have probably gone
for the tail spin first and then
oh my god the one plus two throws okay
maybe he found an opening now bubsy
maybe so maybe definitely ease maybe you
know you can't break them all with king
okay now scary time
it whiffed but he is a brave man because
we know how rage drives and their
hitboxes go they're very big nice
blocked out they're healthy okay
it's like i'm a halal boy man why are
you trying to send me to johanna for now
no way get him in the corner here we go
can wrap work his way out
nice see that alternate potato now
taking some of that momentum away but as
i say that just gets can't hit with a
four or four he drops your comforter
but everything just seems to be hitting
everything
he's managed to work his way out that
corner rage available now nice punish on
the back one way for the job here we go
now rifle back on board it seems so
scary literally that whole section
everything here
it's how does he have these answers here
we go multiple one out of three guess
okay goes for the sharp shooter this
time bret hart
oh boy
okay doggy
okay needs to be very careful nice
scouts the hell sweet
no he goes for the hard combo and drops
it could could just come back to haunt
him no it's not that's dead no
what is he doing
this is scary times do you see the down
jab just to alleviate the pressure oh it
was a float
oh it doesn't get the wall though
oh
is it going to be too overrated what was
that so he probably thought the one down
three was coming down the three three
which is the mid
yeah great it just shows rafe is just so
aware and ready he's in the opponent's
head
once again he missed times is okay the
up four to the side step punch the
instant break on the giant swing he is
playing so well right now he's in the
zone ultra instinct rafe
he he wave dash into throw break
he's in the zone bro he he waved oh that
was a car hit bro
oh no
i'll change the potential he's on the
back foot now rage available and rafe
ladies and lads it's going to go up too
oh look at the pop-up as well he's
feeling himself he's in the zone
if there was ever a time for ultra inc
potato to get a match on the board it
was then
but the one pixel come back bubsy
that was i i i'm actually speechless the
way this guy
his mind is he's not even two steps
ahead this guy's six steps ahead he
already knows what's gonna happen he's
in the future
like he just knew that okay you're
probably gonna try scout for the one
down three and went for the one three
three which is slow but he was just so
ahead and just knew that in this clutch
situation you're probably looking out
for this you're probably looking out for
the lows and the lower parries to try to
get that momentum back and he just
showed that no i am ahead of you he hits
that mid and he made that comeback
and
like i said that that is when you make
that kind of comeback the momentum shift
and
how it mentally affects you he just
literally snatched that away again and
he is really looking on i don't know
i i think i've said this so many times
he
i don't know how you're gonna stop him
he's looking yeah
it's looking rough now but ultron's a
potato has to make a decision now does
he go to infinite does he go to uh the
the forgotten realm he needs to do
something different right yeah he's
keeping it close but rafe is his
comeback factor his clutch his mind game
he's making ultra insane potato doubt
himself what we've been seeing all day
today and many tournaments entered we
always see ultra potato making the right
decisions and now rafe is forcing him to
make the wrong decisions by making him
doubt himself with all of his reads so
now rafe you know the mind game is real
the mind game is so so real didn't stop
going for the hell sleep either but
ladies and gents this could potentially
be the final match here if rafe can take
it he worked his way all the way from
the loser bracket early on today making
it through losers run the gauntlet and
now he's one match away from winning the
entire tournament
here we go definitely last chance saloon
he is locked in with king he has to ride
this all out with king but already he's
off to a bad start
yeah
okay
okay he's at four four two okay using
the laws but just one respect him
he
how is he oh i don't know i'm speechless
at this minute
yeah he sees the win he can see it man
rape he wants to finish it early not let
potato get any opportunity for a
comeback he got hit by damn back three
and just went for while 72 in a hit
everything this man does is working
everything he touches turns to gold to
maddest
okay okay nice guess i can't hit there
could be start something from ultra
potato
oh mrs the ground floor okay nice punish
oh that's another account it could have
ripped it looks like he's bringing
something back but this is when it gets
scary when ray starts getting that
momentum
okay all the timing the timing the
timing
okay
a ghostly giant and he breaks the giant
swing
yeah this guy's throw breaking is on
point
oh sweet this could be dead he's gonna
go for the rage on ladies and lads we
are gonna go to tournament point now
rafe from saudi arabia looking to take
it all this guy
i i i should leave bro this is crazy
here we go
he's going to take him to the corner and
i'll potentially break the wall
big combo conversion okay this time it's
time to ice k and get the car here
this is rage is available this is last
chance what's he going to do now this is
last hit
oh my god he's going to finish it in
style rafe is he going to finish it with
a seven golden letters yola can he
finish it right now no break on the
shining wizard okay this can this be a
comeback for for all shaking some potato
does have rage available no
ladies and lads ray from saudi arabia is
going to be your tekken online challenge
middle east master champion after being
put into losers bracket so early on
running the gauntlet and taking it all
that was an amazing
so we've got our answer no one could
stop him once he had that momentum
no one could stop him like
wow i don't i don't know he played out
of his mind the way he was like five
steps ahead of his opponent his throw
break and everything
he he played i think
more or less nearly perfect
right yeah i mean it's amazing
this is something that i need to i want
to stress right because i've said it
before
right that this that saudi arabia is a
theme to look out for because they have
not had their real opportunity
to travel the world and show what
they're made of we've seen we've seen
inklings of them we've seen a couple of
them like bmns and kayal ins in america
we've seen them at the dubai master
event we saw what luffy was able to do
even beating people like aslan but the
saudis are said to me and we've seen
them in tournaments as well that there
are so many saudis at our top level that
we haven't been able to see compete on
the world stage and i for one cannot
wait to see more of these um
saudi arabian top talented players
travel the world get picked up by
sponsors and start to to just destroy
players that we've known to be top guys
for a very very long time because that's
what tekken is about that's what it's
been about for such a long time
definitely
so i guess we can to see the um the
ticker going on the bottom for the uh
current rankings i guess we can get the
rankings the leaderboards up now just to
show it and show what that actually
means so oh potatoes still in the lead
he was sitting pretty before but rafe
just look at that with that win he he's
sitting pretty almost double from
third place complain so
that was a huge win for him and with
that momentum i'm not i won't be
surprised if he takes this this that
momentum he had further on and
we see him like down the line in the twt
finals
yeah and you know remember as well that
um
when it comes to the dojo events you
know uh you have up until october 10th
to sign up as a tournament organizer and
if you guys are watching saudi arabia
any of you guys watching i'm sure there
are some tournament organizers watching
in saudi arabia get signed up for those
man make some dojo online events that
your players can compete in and get some
points to see the dates here for the
online masters today was middle east
thank you so much for everyone tuning in
but the action does not stop as next
week and the following weeks after this
we're gonna have south asia south east
asia more talent that we got with that
maybe you guys haven't heard of are
gonna be breaking onto the scene um
and of course then the regional finals
are listed there on the right too but
the most important thing is if you're in
saudi arabia or wherever you are around
the world make sure that you sign uh if
you are entered into the into the the
tournaments that you register yourself
to be part of the leaderboard so let's
say for example ray if he didn't sign up
then all those points wouldn't have
meant anything right so you have to sign
up as you can see on the link there get
yourself signed up and you only have up
until october to do so and if you're a
total organizer uh very important as
well you have up until uh october 10th
to sign up to your tournament to become
an official dojo event so that your
players can actually end up competing
and making and getting more points right
i believe that depending on how high
your your your sign ups are for the dojo
events you can potentially make out up
to 100 points for winning a dojo right
as we've been seeing week after week on
the icfc's uh but it's open to everyone
ladies and gents so make sure you submit
your application uh but basically man
holy cow this has been an amazing
tournament it was definitely amazing but
before that make sure to follow um b e
sports on both the twitter and the
youtube and obviously follow tekken on
twitter twitch and facebook for all the
latest you know updates and going ons
within the tekken community within the
tekken twt tour but yeah
oh
it was an amazing i'm still kind of
speechless from what i saw i'm i'm
literally that was probably one of the
cleanest gin plays i've seen like he
just he i said it before he almost
he was played perfect like he was making
the reads he was steps ahead his
execution was great combos like
conversions like
list goes on fro breaking wall
positioning
i feel like look this is something i
want to say like uh shout out to the
georgian scene because the georgian
scene is extremely strong they're a
small but very powerful strong tight
knit community and i can't wait to one
day travel in charlotte to to to that
country and learn more about your
players shout outs to israel as well you
know for putting on a good show you had
multiple players up in the top 16. and
but saudi arabia man there are players
like mad wolf federer shrimp shrimp who
managed to downfall to electric uh and
beat the [ __ ] out of cool dams you know
in an offline tournament but mad wolf
who beat nobi so badly that nobody just
all he did all he had to do was just
like he just laughed and just walked
away like there was nothing he could do
not like
literally just laughed and walked away
like like people in saudi arabia shout
out to your scene keep doing your thing
because the time will come where you
guys get to um get to play and and show
what you're made of man so today was a a
good opportunity to show you know what
what the talent is there and rife man he
showed it man he showed it for sure
definitely showed it and i'm looking
forward to seeing fervent on the land
what actually comes i i hope to see him
later on in the twt um
playing against i guess more global
opponents as well and taking it outside
and playing some of the best and that's
when you get these good matches these
these legendary matches these timeless
classic matches so yeah shout outs to
rafe you know getting that first place
how's the old train sweet potato too he
played he played well as well he played
very well um he's still sitting pretty
in the leaderboards as well number one
so
big shout out saying big thanks to
everyone that played and took part in
the um
in the tlc uh middle east big shout out
to all you guys big shout out to
everyone i watched as well at home
you know the team
gonna be available we've been watching
you know
put it on the show for you guys so speak
shout out to you guys for watching too
so yeah yeah man and next week of course
it's gonna be the south asia i believe
in south south east asia and master
events so make sure to uh tune in for
that and that's going to be it from us
ladies and lads uh thank you so much for
tuning in uh i hope you enjoyed it bob's
a pleasure to commentate with you again
man it's been too long man world tour
we'll do it again man they said bubsy
the return of bob's the legend man if it
wasn't for
that's going to be it from us thank you
so much for tuning in and we will catch
you next time
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
hello
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
that's
[Music]
[Music]
you